WHAT DO THESE EIGHTY. YEAHOKAY
A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OF APRIL
TWENTIETH- WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM SO. I WILL WAIT TO CALL
FOR CORN TILL SUCH TIME AS IT
APPEARS WE HAVE ONE- I'D LIKE TO
ORDER THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL NOT BE ON PHONES
TODAY. SCHOOLS ARE OPEN THIS
COMMITTEES OPEN. ALL WE'VE
EIGHTEEN BILLS ON FILE TODAY
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE WILL BE
HEARING BILLS IN FILE ORDER ONE
BILL'S BEEN PULLED FROM THE
AGENDA THAT BILL IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
EIGHT HAS BEEN PULLED. OTHER
FIVE MEASURES ON CONSENT TODAY
THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS.
AB TWO FIVE ZERO EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS AB TWO SIX ONE SEVEN
AB TWO EIGHT TWO SEVEN. HR ONE
ON ONE WITH AMENDMENTS- WITH THE
AGREEMENT OF VICE CHAIR AND
PURSUANT TO OUR COMMITTEE RULES
WILL BE WAVING THE AUTHOR'S
PRESENTATION ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FOR OR
AGAINST THIS MEASURE WHEN IT IS
TAKEN UP-MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ARE WELCOME PROVIDE COMMENT IN
PERSON IN PERSON. JUST WHEN YOU
DO COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
JUST SAY YOUR NAME. AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
DON'T MAKE ME GO BERMAN ON YOUR. LET'S HAVE SOME FUN- WITH THAT
WE WILL PROCEED TO OUR FIRST
ITEM WHICH IS WAS TO BE AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE AND
THEY'RE NOT PRESENT YET SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH MS AGUIAR-CURRY
. WITH AND FIVE FILE ITEM FIVE
WHICH IS AB SEVENTEEN SEVEN.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. THIS IS
YOUR CREAMY. PROCEED ONE READY.
IT PAYS TO GET HERE N TIME. IT
DOES. USUALLY GET PAID BECAUSE
YOU'RE ON TIME THIS PLACE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
- GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL AND
FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH MY
STAFF TO ENSURE ITS INTENT IS
MET. I WILL EXPLORE BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN EXPANDS
EDUCATION ACCESS TO MIGRANT
STUDENTS IN TRANSITIONAL.
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH SIXTH GRADE
SPECIFICALLY IT ALLOWS TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO ACCESS
FUNDING FOR THE MIGRANT STUDENTS
TO ATTEND COMPREHENSIVE
SCHOOLING DURING THE MONTHS THAT
MATCH THEIR- FAMILIES MOVEMENT
FOR WORK. IN A CALIFORNIA HOME
TO ONE OF EVERY THREE MIGRANT
STUDENTS IN THE COUNTRY AS OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MORE THAN
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND. MIGRANTS
STUDENTS LIVED IN CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN HALF OF THE STUDENTS
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS. MIGRANT
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ALREADY MANY CHALLENGES THE SO.
MIGRANT WORKERS OFTENTIMES
STUDENTS MOVE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES BASED ON SEASONAL
AGRICULTURAL C. SEASONS AND ARE
UNABLE TO STAY AT THE SAME
SCHOOL FOR A FULL ACADEMIC YEAR.
LET ALONE LONG TERM MIGRANTS
LONG TERM MY GO FAMILIES ALSO
STRUGGLE WITH THE CHALLENGES-RELATED TO LACK OF AVAILABLE
HOUSING FOOD INSECURITY IN
LIMITED ACCESS TO CULTURALLY
COMPETENT RESOURCES. STUDENTS
SHOULD NOT BE EXPECTED TO WORRY
ABOUT RECEIVING A FULL YEAR OF
SCHOOL. AS STUDENTS MOVE FROM
DISTRICT TO DISTRICT THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR THEY ARE ALSO LESSEN.
SUCCEED IN SCHOOL AND ARE OFTEN
ISOLATED FROM THEIR PEERS.
PASSING A. B. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WILL WORK TO ENSURE THAT
MIGRANT STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE
ACCESS TO. THE HIGH QUALITY AND
CONTINUOUS EDUCATION THEY
DESERVE. WITH ME TODAY I TESTED
FOR THE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BILINGUAL EDUCATION. THANK YOU-
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY TEAR WITNESSES
TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
MAKE PERCY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JENNIFER BAKER I ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION WE BELIEVE THE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
CONTINUOUS ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
IS A LARGE AMOUNT OF MIGRANT
STUDENT THAT STUDENTS THAT
DESERVE THE SAME QUALITY OF
EDUCATION AND ACCESS IS ALL
OTHER STUDENTS. WE APPRECIATE
THE MEASURES- AND INTENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE STUDENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL- WE
PARTICULARLY WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
IN 200-016-1770 PER PERCENT OF
MIGRANT STUDENTS DID NOT MEET
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS STANDARDS
COMPARED TO FIFTY THREE PERCENT.
OF THE GENERAL STUDENT
POPULATION MEASURES LIKE THIS
WILL WORK TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE HAVE
THOSE SAME EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT WE CAN TRY
TO ELIMINATE SYSTEMIC LONG TERM
GAPS IN THEIR EDUCATION AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OTHER WITNESSES.
NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT MAY COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE STATE THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION OF
THE ONLY PLACE. NICK ROMAN WE
HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT. LASHOF
DAVID MURPHY WITH CALIFORNIA
SUPERINTENDENTS
AND SUPPORT. NONETHELESS FEDERAL
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU SAY NO THERE'S IN
SUPPORT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
. THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY SEEN
OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION. IT
WAS THE LAND OF THE BILL SAYING
I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE WELL
WE ARE GOING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HINAULT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE GONNA WAIT
TO TAKE A MOTION BECAUSE WE DO
NOT YET. HAVE A QUORUM. THE WET
THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR HELP
AND TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF. PORTABLE THANK YOU.
OUR WAITING FOR MISS BONTA
WEARING FORMS BOERNER HORVATH
RANGER MISTER CUNNINGHAM. IT'S
NOT WANT TO WAIT THAT
OCEANOGRAPHERS AND AT ALL
CORRECT OKAY. YEAH OKAY
DISREGARD THAT LAST NAME- IRWIN
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. WITH THE WIN
WE DIDN'T WIN YEAH BUT WE CAN'T
MAKE A MOTION TO THE- YOU KNOW
MAKE. SO YEAH YEAH OTHERS MUST
BONTA SUMMERS BY IS HERE WITH-
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. AB TWO
FOUR SIX FIVE. DID YOU WOULD YOU
WANT TO START WITH FIVE THREE
YOU TELL ME. I DON'T KNOW YOU
HAD A WITNESS I BELIEVE THAT WAS
GOING TO BE HERE MAY STILL BE
AROUND HER. ANYONE WHAT. WAS HER
ONE. OKAY FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO
FOUR SIX FIVE RESPOND TO ME. GO
AHEAD THANK YOU A GOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL FEEDBACK AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FIVE IS INSPIRED BY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT'S TASK FORCE TO
IMPROVE READING BY THIRD GRADE.
THIS BILL CREATES A GRANT
PROGRAM TO ENGAGE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND IMPROVING
LITERACY AND BY LITERACY
OUTCOMES TO REALIZE THE VISION
OF UNIVERSAL CHILDHOOD LITERACY
BY THIRD GRADE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR GRANT FUNDS TO DESIGN A
FAMILY LITERACY IN BY LITERACY
INNOVATION PLAN INCORPORATING
THREE OF THE FOLLOWING FIVE
STRATEGIES INCLUDING FAMILY
LITERACY PLANS. FAMILY LITERACY
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS BILINGUAL
FAMILY LITERACY FROM A TODAS OR
OUTREACH COORDINATORS EXTENDED
DAY SUMMER OR WEAKENED
INSTITUTES RELATED TO LITERACY
IN BY LITERACY AND LIBRARY
FAMILY LITERACY PARTNERSHIPS AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE ALSO
AUTHORIZES FUNDING FOR DIGITAL
TOOLS TO PROMOTE FAMILY LITERACY
. TIONAL TEN MILLION DOLLARS. IN
PURPOSE MEMBERS I WANTED THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST BILL I AGREE
TO AUTHOR THIS ISSUE IS VERY
PERSONAL TO ME- PRIOR TO JOINING
YOU ON THE GREEN CARPET I SPENT
MY CAREER LEADING NONPROFITS
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING EDUCATIONAL
OUTPUTS OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING POVERTY
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON EARLY
LITERACY WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS
WHO ARE ABLE TO READ BY THIRD
GRADE ARE FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO GRADUATE THAN STUDENTS WHO
ARE UNABLE TO DO SO. AND
CURRENTLY ACCORDING TO THE
NATION'S REPORT CARD ONLY 32% OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH GRADERS ARE
READING PROFICIENTLY. THESE
RESULTS BUT CALIFORNIA BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND BEHIND
TWENTY FIVE OTHER STATES.
FURTHER THE DATA DEMONSTRATES
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN READING
PROFICIENCY IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ONLY 18% OF BLACK FOURTH
GRADERS. TESTED PROFICIENT
PROFICIENTLY COMPARED 223% OF
LATINO FOURTH GRADERS. AND 45%
OF WHAT FOURTH GRADERS. THE
RESEARCH MAKES IT CLEAR THAT AS
LITERACY IS THE FOUNDATION FOR
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS. LITERACY IS
THE KEY TO EQUITY AND WITH A
STRONG CORRELATION BETWEEN
LITERACY AND HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. LITERACY IS A PATH
TO BREAKING THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE. WITH THAT I HAVE MEET
WITH ME TESTIFYING TODAY THE ARE
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION OFFICE. MR TONY
THURMOND AND- ALEXANDER DE
CAPRIO SENIOR STRATEGIST AT
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
YOUR WITNESSES OR WITNESSES HERE
ONE IS OKAY I'M SORRY. YOUR
RECEIPT AN AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEX DA
CAPRIO AND I'M A SENIOR
STRATEGIST AT FIRST SIGHT
CALIFORNIA THE STATE'S
COMMISSION ON CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY. AT FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA OUR GOAL IS TO
ENSURE ALL CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE
HAVE THE SAFE STABLE NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS AND ENVIRONMENTS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT AND EARLY LITERACY
IS A KEY STRATEGY TO SUPPORT
THIS GOAL. TO TRULY PREPARE
CHILDREN FOR CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
AND REDUCE ACHIEVEMENT
DISPARITIES A SOLID FOUNDATION
OF EARLY LITERACY SKILLS AS
NECESSARY. RESEARCH DOES THE
ROOTS OF THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
START LONG BEFORE CHILDREN ENTER
KINDERGARTEN A MAJOR INDICATOR
FOR LATER SCHOOL SUCCESS AS
LANGUAGE AND EARLY LITERACY
DEVELOPMENT AND DISPARITIES
REALLY VOCABULARY GROWTH BETWEEN
CHILDREN FROM LOW SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS AND HIGHER SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS HAVE BEEN SHOWN CHILDREN
AS EARLY AS SIXTEEN MONTHS OF
AGE. READING ALSO PROMOTES THE
TYPE OF NURSE NURTURING
INTERACTIONS THAT ARE BENEFICIAL
FOR BOTH CHILDREN AND ADULTS AS
WE KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT
ISOLATION AND EXTREME STRESS TO
OUR FAMILIES AND WE PLAY
LITERACY AS AN IMPORTANT
STRATEGY TO HELP FAMILIES BOND
CREATE NURTURING SPACES AND
MOMENTS BETWEEN PARENT CHILD AND
PROVIDE MITIGATION AGAINST
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
BUT IN ORDER FOR THIS TO OCCUR
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
FAMILIES WITH THE TOOLS AND
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO ENGAGE
WITH THEIR CHILD AROUND BOOKS
AND OTHER LITERACY RESOURCES.
FOR THESE REASONS FIRST I
CALIFORNIA'S IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE AND
IT IS AS EXCITED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IT HOLDS FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPROVING THE LITERACY OF YOUNG
CHILDREN BECAUSE AS WE KNOW.
LITERACY IS MORE THAN JUST
GETTING A BOOK INTO A CHILD'S
HAND THIS BILL ACKNOWLEDGES THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT FAMILIES PLAY
IN THEIR CHILDREN'S SCHOOL
SUCCESS AND TARGETS RESOURCES TO
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHO
NEED IT MOST. THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY LITERACY INNOVATION
PROJECT AS PROPOSED IN AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FIVE WOULD ESTABLISH
A STRONG AND- THE NEW SUPPORT
AND CREATE. A C. I. INCLUDING
STE. LIKE FAMILY LAW. PLAN AND
HOME. THIS LEGISLATION ENSURES
THAT FAMILIES SEE THEIR
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THEIR CHILD'S
LITERACY DEVELOPMENT. AND HAVE
ACCESS TO INDIVIDUALIZED
RESOURCES TO MEET THEIR CHILD'S
NEEDS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT AS WALKED IN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU SO
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO PROVIDE
THAT TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE I LIKE TO
ALIGN MYSELF. WITH THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU JUST HEARD. AND THANK
OUR WONDERFUL AUTHOR FOR. A
LEADERSHIP IN STATE. OF THIS
ISSUE- I THINK THE CONTACT HAS
BEEN SET FOR YOU ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF LITERACY. AND WHEN
YOU PLAN- FAMILY ENGAGEMENT IN
THAT CONVERSATION MAKING SURE
THAT FAMILIES UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF. READING HAVE
ACCESS TO BOOKS AND MULTI
CULTURAL SUPPORTS WE KNOW THAT
WE CAN HELP OUR FAMILIES GET
THEIR- THIS IS A GAME CHANGER
AND YOU ALL KNOW THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CHILDREN LEARN TO READ
BY THIRD GRADE. AS OUR CHILDREN
THE COMING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC I
CAN'T THINK OF A MORE IMPORTANT
SKILL TO BUILD FOR THEM. C. TO
ENSURE THAT THEY GRADUATE IN A
PREPARED FOR A GREAT FUTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTER THAT IS
THAT IF YOU'RE TO INITIATIVE.
BOB BUT WITH THAT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT MAY COME FORWARD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF FROST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL LIBRARY ASSOCIATION WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS IT HAS
BEEN PARED DOWN AND AMENDED. IF
I COULD I JUST WANTED TO VERY
QUICKLY NOTE THAT ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS ELIMINATED FROM THE
BILL WAS AN UPDATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MODEL SCHOOL
LIBRARY STANDARDS. I WOULD URGE
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TO TAKE THIS
ISSUE UP IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE IT REALLY
DOESN'T NEED ANY MONEY- WHAT IT
REALLY NEEDS TO SLIP A SLATE OF
A FORTY TO MOVE FORWARD AND
THANK YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
THANK YOU. YES THE LEVEL
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER INSTRUCTS
APART. JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. A SINGLE
OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- THIS IS PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE CAN
DO SUPPORTING EARLY LITERACY.
IT'S REALLY NOT EVEN EARLY
LITERACY WRITERS LITERACY- IF A
CHILD LEAVES THE THIRD GRADE NOT
READING AT GRADE LEVEL THERE'S A
75% CHANCE THAT SHALL NEVER
WILL. READ AT GRADE LEVEL SO
THIS ISSUE IS HUGE IT'S
SOMETHING THE STATE. HAS
GRAPPLED WITH FOR YEARS AND
STILL DOES SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO IT. BECAUSE YOU GET
IT THIS IS IT RIGHT HERE. THIS
IS A BIG BIG DEAL- IT'S LEARN TO
READ. WRITE AND THEN READ THE
LOOKING AT READ LEARN LEARN TO
READ WRITE. LEARN TO READ READ
LEARN- SO I APPRECIATE THE BILL
AND I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT AND
RECOGNIZE THAT MORE RESOURCES
NEED TO GO INTO THIS EFFORT- AND
AGAIN THANK YOU. SO THAT I ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHICH
COMMON. SAYING NO OTHER- OF
COMMENTS DO. YOU KNOW HOW WE
DON'T WE DON'T KNOW FORM YET SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT. TO
MAKE A MOTION. SO WITH THAT-
WILL MOVE TO YOUR THIRD BILL A
DRIVE ITEM THREE I'M SORRY FIVE
THREE. AB NINETEEN TWELVE OF I
MISS BONTA AGAIN EMERGENCY
PORTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT. ENJOY YOUR
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
FIRST I WANT TO SHARE THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
FOURTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
ENGAGEMENTS ON THIS ISSUE. AB
NINETEEN TWELVE CREATES A NEW
PROCESS FOR SCHOOLS IN FINANCIAL
DISTRESS. WHO NEED TO FOLLOW
THAT THEY NEED TO FOLLOW WHEN
CONSIDERING SCHOOL CLOSURE INC
STOCK AND CONSOLIDATIONS AS A
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I
KNOW THAT SCHOOL CLOSURES NOT
EASY DECISIONS TO MAKE THEY ARE
EMOTIONAL DECISIONS. IMPACTING
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TEACHERS
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. IF
NOT DONE TRANSPARENCY
TRANSPARENTLY WITH COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT THERE'S A MISTRUST IN
THE PROCESS THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED WITH MY CONSTITUENTS
AND HOW THEY ARE FEELING NOW
WITH RECENT DECISIONS MADE. IN
THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FEELING PRSSURE TO
MAKE A DECISION IN ORDER TO GET
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS PROMISED
IN LAST BUDGET THE BOARD OF A
USD SWIFT COMPILED TO SCHOOLS
SLATED FOR CLOSURE CONSOLIDATION
. VERY LITTLE NOTIFICATION
COMMUNITY THERE WAS CONFUSION
SHOCK AND DISBELIEF ABOUT THIS
PRECIPITOUS ACTION PARENTS
STUDENTS AND HUNGER STRIKERS
PROTESTED I SPENT HOURS WITH ALL
OF THEM TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE DISTRICT COULD HAVE
DONE DIFFERENTLY INCLUDING WITH
BOARD MEMBERS AND STILL THE
COMMUNITY STUDENTS FAMILIES DO
NOT HAVE A RESOLUTION IN FACT TO
THE ACLU HAS CURRENTLY BROUGHT
ACTION AGAINST. THE UST SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO TRY TO RECTIFY THE
SITUATION THIS IS WHY AB
NINETEEN TWELVE IS VERY PERSONAL
TO ME AND IT'S PERSONAL TO
STUDENTS EDUCATORS SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AS WELL WHO CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF NOT ONLY A
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS- AT BUT ALSO
THE OTHER KINDS OF ANALYSES THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR MAKING THESE
CRITICAL DECISIONS. AB NINETEEN
TWELVE WILL REQUIRE SCHOOLS IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS DEFINED AS
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE A STUDENT A
STATE LOAN OR UNDER RECEIVERSHIP
TO CONDUCT AN EQUITY IMPACT
ANALYSIS. TO GUIDE THE
IDENTIFICATION OF SCHOOLS TO BE
CLOSED OR CONSOLIDATED. THIS
EQUITY IMPACT ANALYSIS MINIMUM
WILL NEED TO LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
METRICS THAT INCLUDE. OPERATING
COST OF A SCHOOL AND THE
ASSOCIATED SAVINGS RESULTING
FROM A SCHOOL CLOSURE OR
CONSOLIDATION. SPECIAL PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE AT THE SCHOOLS BEING
CONSIDERED FOR CLOSURE OR
CONSOLIDATION AND WHETHER THOSE
PROGRAMS WILL BE PROVIDED AT THE
SAME CURRENT LEVEL AT THE
SCHOOLS TO WHICH PEOPLE TO BE
DIVERTED. AND BALANCE OF PEOPLE
DEMOGRAPHICS INCLUDING RACE OR
ETHNICITY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ENGLISH LEARNERS
FOSTER YOUTH AND HOMELESS YOUTH
IN THE SCHOOLS BEING CONSIDERED
FOR CLOSURE OR CONSOLIDATION.
BUILDER REX THE SCHOOL SENT THE
METRICS THAT WILL BE USED IN
THEIR EQUITY IMPACT ANALYSIS AT
THE BOARD MEETING. ONCE A LIST
OF PROPOSED SCHOOL SCHOOL
CLOSURES IS DEVELOPED THE BOARD
WILL PRESENT THAT LIST OF THE
COMMUNITY AND SHARE HOW IT
IDENTIFIED THE SCHOOLS. ON THE
FOUR ON THE LIST AT A MINIMUM
THE PORTAL SHARE WITH THE
COMMUNITY THE FOLLOWING FACTORS
USED TO IDENTIFY THE LIST OF
SCHOOL CLOSURES OR
CONSOLIDATIONS EQUITY IMPACT
ANALYSIS FINDINGS FOR EACH
SCHOOL CLOSURE OR CONSOLIDATION.
PLAN FOR THE USE OF THE SCHOOLS
PROPOSED FOR CLOSURE
CONSOLIDATION ONCE IT BECOMES A
VACATED FACILITY. CRITERIA USED
TO ASSIGN DISPLACED PEOPLE TO
OTHER SUCH SCHOOL SITES OR
DESCRIPTION OF THE PROCESS OF
REASSIGNMENT THAT WILL BE USED
BY THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND-
OPTIONS AND TIMELINE FOR
TRANSITIONING PEOPLE'S TO THEIR
NEW SCHOOLS INCLUDING IMPROVING
SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL. AND
SCHOOLS INTERSECTIONS. AB
NINETEEN TWELVE DIRECTS THE
BOARD TO TAKE FEEDBACK INTO
CONSTRICTED RATIONING WHEN
DEVELOPING ITS FINAL LIST OF
SCHOOL CLOSURES. THIS BILL IS A
DIRECT RESPONSE TO WHAT HAPPENED
IN MY DISTRICT BUT QUITE FRANKLY
WITH THE IT WILL IMPACT OTHER
DISTRICTS ARE FACING DIFFICULT
DECISIONS REGARDING SCHOOL
CLOSURES IN THE FUTURE. HERE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
ORDER THE BILL ARE KATE HARDIMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND KIMBERLY ROSS
AND BURGER WITH SEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KATE KATIE HARTMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. I APOLOGIZE THEY
RAN HERE FROM SENATE AD SO I'M
STILL OUT OF BREATH- IT THESE
DAYS IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
TWELVE AND WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. SCHOOLS ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
CTA BELIEVES SCHOOL CLOSURES ARE
DISRUPTIVE AND DETRIMENTAL TO
THE EDUCATION OF STUDENTS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY LIVE IN. DECISIONS
AROUND SCHOOL CLOSURES SHOULD
NOT BE TAKEN LIGHTLY AND SHOULD
BE MADE YOU SHOULD NOT BE MADE
UNILATERALLY BY WHATEVER SCHOOL
CLOSURES ARE CONSIDERED ALL THE
IMPACTS ON THE COMMUNITY SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED INCLUDING
DISPROPORTIONAL IMPACT ON BOTH
VULNERABLE STUDENT GROUPS.
DEFINITELY THE PROCESS FOR
CLOSURE SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT
AND INCLUDE INPUT FROM COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE- A SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
FISCAL DISCRET DISTRESS TO
CONDUCT AN EQUITY IMPACT
ANALYSIS BEFORE APPROVING ANY
MERGERS WE BELIEVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SOULD ALREADY BE
DOING THAT. PRACTICE AT THE
CENTRAL IN MITIGATING THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. BUT STUDENTS. ALL
STUDENTS DESERVE ACCESS TO A
QUALITY EDUCATION IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ALL OF
THE IMPACT. ON STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES FOR PROVING SCHOOL
CLOSURES AYE URGENT AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT. CAN ROSENBERGER
WITH S. WE REPRESENT THE MOST
POPULOUS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING OAKLAND AND THE IMPACT
THAT THOSE CLOSURES HAD IN THE
MANNER IN WHICH WAS DONE WAS
DEVASTATING NOT ONLY TO THE
COMMUNITY BUT THE WORK FORCE IN
THE STUDENTS- PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CANNOT OPERATE IN THE SAME WAY
AS BUSINESSES IN BLACK AND WHITE
AND DOLLARS AND CENTS OR NEEDS
TO BE A WHOLE PICTURE- AND WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL TAKES AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP AND LOOKING
AT THE EQUITY. AND OTHER FACTORS
THAT IMPROVE THE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE THAT ARE- THE STUDENTS IN
THE WORK FORCE AS WELL- IT THIS
ISN'T JUST. PERSON IF FOR
ALMONDS IN A LOW INCOME HI NEED
FORMAL POPULATIONS- AND WE ARE
SEEING CONSISTENTLY AND MORE
RECENTLY HAPPENING IN URBAN
AREAS SO WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP. AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE AUTHOR
FOR HAVING THIS CONVERSATION AND
ADDING THE EQUITY LINES AND
BRING THE COMMUNITY IT. SENATE
DR- THANK YOU OTHERS IN THE ROOM
IS. MAKE TO MICROPHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS WELL WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL WE ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN THE EQUITY IMPACT
ANALYSIS PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
AND THE OTHER PROVISIONS STATED.
BY OUR COLLEAGUES AND THE POOR
TO WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- ZENO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- YOU ARE US
BECAUSE IT'S COMING TO A
NEIGHBORHOOD. NEAR ME NEAR EVERY
MEMBER IN THIS ROOM SO. IT'S
SCHOOL CLOSURES. RIGHT THE
POPULATION THE STUDENT
POPULATION THAT BUBBLE. IS ABOUT
WHAT. EIGHT YEARS AHEAD OF US
NOW SO IT STARTED TO DROP. ON
THE NATURAL FOR RADIO FACTORS.
AND SO EVERY MEMBER. IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
GRAPPLE ONE ISSUE. THAT CAME TO
YOU FIRST. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN FOR YOUR OWN COMMUNITY
BUT A GREAT VOICE. FOR YOUR WN
COMMUNITY IN YOUR YOUR THIS IS
THE FIRST WAVE AND IT'S HITTING
YOU. AND YOU'RE HERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO MANAGE IT AND IT'S
BEEN TOUGH. I KNOW I KNOW IT'S
TOUGH- AND YOU'RE KIND OF. RIGHT
NOW YOU'RE KIND OF. BUILD A
PLACE YOU FLAG IS HOW DO WE
RESPOND WHEN IT DISTRICT- IN THE
EYES OF MANY- ACTED HASTE. WITH
HASTE AND DIDN'T REALLY INCLUDE
THE COMMUNITY AND GET ADEQUATE
INPUT SO I COMMEND YOU. FOR
STANDING UP. FOR THE SCHOOLS FOR
THE SCHOOLS OR DISTRICTS. I
WOULD SAY ONE WAY WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THOUGH. ACROSS THE
STATE THIS. THING WRONG SMALL
SCHOOL. RIGHT THE DISTRICTS HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT RIGHT
NOW. DISTRICTS CANNOT AFFORD
SMALL SCHOOLS. SO WE NEED TO DO.
AND BUDGET BECAUSE THE MONEY
WILL BE THERE AND THAT'S ONGOING
MONEY. TO ADD TO THE BASE. .
GOVERNOR'S OFFER A PROPOSAL THIS
WILL CHANGE IS FIVE POINT THREE
THREE WILL. THE NAME BE
INFLATION. NOR'EASTERS A PURSE
COSTS THERE OTHER COST PRESSURES
ON DISTRICT PLANNING ROMAN
EXETER. RIGHT WE REALLY NEED TO
RAISE THAT BASE TO KIND OF STAVE
OFF. SOME OF THE SITUATIONS- THE
SITUATION IF YOU WILL THAT'S
OCCURRING IN YOUR DISTRICT
BECAUSE- IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
EITHER WAY. BUT THE SAME TIME IT
CAN BE LESSENED IF DISTRICTS ARE
BETTER FINANCED. BECAUSE IT
THEIR DISTRICTS ARE MAKING
FINANCIAL. ISSUES WHICH HAVE
HUMAN IMPACT SO I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR YOUR
DISTRICT HERE TODAY AND I HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST. AND APPRECIATE
THE BILL. ARE THERE ARE OTHERS
ON THE COMMITTEE THAT WISH TO
COMMENT IS QUIRK-SILVA. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND- I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR ABOUT- ISSUE SIMILAR
TO THIS I MEAN WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW IS THE DATA THAT SHOWS.
THAT NOT ONLY IS DECLINING
ENROLLMENT REAL IT'S NOT JUST A-
SHORT PERIOD IT'S BEEN LONG TERM
NOW- BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME
OF THE YOUNGER GENERATION IS
ALSO CHOOSING NOT TO HAVE
CHILDREN. THAT'S ANOTHER FACTOR
THAT WILL PLAY INTO THIS. BUT
THE OTHER QUESTION IS HOW SMALL
IS TOO SMALL WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
IT. X. I HAVE SOME DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. LITERALLY UNDER FIVE
THOUSAND- STUDENTS THAT ARC THAT
WERE FIVE THOUSAND NOW CLOSER TO
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED SO. I THINK.
THERE'S A LOT TO TALK ABOUT BUT
ONE THING THAT I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT THIS I. DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THIS BILL IS ON THE EQUITY
IMPACT ANALYSIS. IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND
MANY MANY YEARS AS A TEACHER. IS
SOMETIMES ARE COMMUNITIES. OF
COLOR- AS MUCH AS WE WANT TO THE
INCLUDE THEM WHETHER IT'S
LANGUAGE BARRIERS WHETHER IT'S
WORK BARRIERS WHETHER IT'S-
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS WHATEVER
THE REASONS. WE DON'T ALWAYS GET
THEM. AT WHETHER IT'S THE BOARD
MEETING SO HOW IS THE OUT REACH
GOING TO BE MADE TO THEM TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THEIR INPUT IS REALLY
INCLUDED BECAUSE ALL TOO OFTEN.
IT'S WHOEVER SHOWS UP AT THAT
BOARD ROOM THAT NIGHT AND THE
BOARD IS THERE. AND THEN THEY GO
WITH THE MAJORITY. I APPRECIATE
THAT AND AT THAT QUITE FRANKLY-
THAT KIND OF OUTRAGE THAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN FOR COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IS WHY WE END UP WITH DIRE
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE AND- HUNGER STRIKING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEIR VOICES HAVE BEEN HEARD. OR
REPRESENTED OR REFLECTED IN THAT
SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
RAISING THOSE CONCERNS AND I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE CHAIR-
BACKED OUT WE NEED TO INCREASE
OUR BASE FUNDING FORMULA- AND
HOPE THAT WE DO THAT BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT IN THE MEANTIME-
WHENEVER WE CLOSE A SCHOOL IT
CLOSES DOWN. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
- REMEMBRANCE OF SCHOOL MEMORIES
ASSOCIATED WITH ONE SCHOOL. AT
NEIGHBORHOODS GET INCREDIBLY
IMPACTED BY SCHOOL CLOSURES.
WHEN YOU CLOSE DOWN SCHOOLS TO
CLOSE DOWN A LIFELINE TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IN. A MINUTE
PROVIDED PROVISION SOCIAL
SERVICES AND ALL THOSE THINGS
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE UNFORTUNATELY
BEEN BURDENED WITH TAKING ON.
WITHIN A COMMUNITY SO. WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. OKAY I'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES ON RIGHT THANK YOU
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT EVEN
A TRUE CHAMPION- FOR OAKLAND AND
FOR THE FAMILIES WHO ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO ULTIMATELY IMPACT THEIR
CHILDREN. THANK YOU WITH THAT-
WE DO WE HAVE A QUORUM WE DO
HAVE A CONSULATE ESTABLISH
REQUIREMENT IT WILL TAKE A
MOTION. BUT DONALD. HERE DONALD
PRESENT DELHI. DELHI PRESENT
BENNETT. LI THERE WE
PRESENT MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA PRESENT SO WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM SO THAT- I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. IT'S BEEN
MOVEMENTS REALLY AND SECONDED BY
MISS QUIRK-SILVA- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I BELIEVE THAT
WOULD. DEMOCRATS I WAS HONORABLY
. FILE ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN
TWELVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL I DON'T I'D DALLY.
DALLY I. SENATE CHEN LI LI I
MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA
I HAVE FOUR PLUS FOUR FOUR VOTE
SO IT IS OUT WHICH THERE WERE
GONNA ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE- WE DID AT A
QUARTER OF THE TIME SO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS AB TWO FOUR SIX
FIVE HAVE A MOTION AND MOVED BY
MISS DOLLARS SECOND BY MR LEE
THE MOTION ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE OR ALL OF THE SECRETARY
READ. THE CARD CALL. FILE ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL. HI
THE KNOW WHY DALLI. DALLI I.
BENNETT CHEN. PLEASE BE AYE
MCCARTY. QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA
AYE WE HAVE FOUR BUT THOSE FOR
BOTH SO IT IS OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU WILL DO NOW IS
WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS NO TESTIMONY SO.
WE'RE JUST WE'RE JUST I'M- NO
PRESENTATION. OKAY OKAY GOT IT
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR- WE'RE
AMENDING SCHOOLS OUT OF THAT
BILL FILE UNDER FOUR IS THERE
ANY ANY ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
SAYING NINE. COMPORT PLEASE.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS COMMITTEE OUR
MONTHLY CANNOT BE OUT THAT
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION WORDS OF ACTUALLY.
WHEN I TO SUPPORT OUR- BUT THAT
YOU'RE NOT IN SUPPORT. OKAY SO
LET ME STAY THERE OKAY- ANY ANY
PERSONS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
COME FORWARD SAYING THAT ANY
OPPOSITION WE HAVE OPPOSITION
RIGHT HERE SIR YOU MAY PROCEED.
YEAH OUR MONTHLY SANTA BE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION WHERE- WHERE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. OKAY
YOU'RE NOT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL OKAY TODAY WE'RE DOES WE
ARE JUST A MANY OUT SCHOOLS BUT
THANK YOU SIR OKAY- WITH THAT-
IT IS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED-
OUR- SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FOR AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL. I
FORGOT ALL I DALY. DALLY NO
BENNETT SENATE I'D CHEN E. LEAI
MCCARTY. QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA
I WE HAVE FOUR VOTE YES FOR VOTE
SO IT IS OUT IS MOVED ON SO WILL
NOW KNOW SEEMS TO CUNNINGHAM
RIBBONS ON THE MOVED OFF ISLAND
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO ZERO SIX
WARMUS- ONE. YOU MAY COMPORT AND. WELL I'M SIX THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
ISSUE I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED. IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE PROVISIONS
RELATING TO INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIAL AND PUPILS. INSTEAD
THESE CHANGES WILL REFOCUS THE
BILL ON THE STATE LIBRARY
PROVIDING MEDIA LITERACY
RESOURCES TO INDIVIDUALS HAD
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL LIBRARIES.
EVERY INDIVIDUAL PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE. IN RECOGNIZING
AND BUILDING RESILIENCE TO FALSE
AND HARMFUL NARRATIVES THAT IS
WHY CREATING A CULTURE OF. AT A
EARLY AGENTS. THREE ADULTHOOD IS
KEY TWENTY SIXTY FOUR WILL
RECOGNIZE AN UPLIFT LIBRARIANS
AS IDEAL LEADERS. IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL GREAT
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. THERE YOU GO ME. WELL
MISTER CHAIRMAN JEFF FROSTRUP IS
IN THE CALIFORNIASCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION AS YOUR- ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL BILLS ON THIS TOPIC OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS- NOBODY'S
BEEN ABLE TO SORT OF FIND THE
RIGHT SPOT I THINK THIS BILL AS
AMENDED DOES THAT- WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL- THE
OTHER POINT THAT I WANTED TO
MAKE IS THAT- ANALYSIS ALSO
REFERENCES THE MODEL SCHOOL
LIBRARY STANDARDS WHERE MEDIA
LITERACY IS A PART OF THAT.
THOSE STANDARDS ARE TWELVE YEARS
OLD THINK OF THE DIFFERENCE IN
OUR MEDIA INTERACTION IN THAT
TIME IT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY THE
MODEL STANDARDS SHOULD BE
UPDATED THANK YOU. AND ANY OTHER
SPORTS IN ORDER TO SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION. SINGLE OPPOSITION
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE SECOND DEPEND MODES BEEN
MOVED BY MR ALI'S SECOND BY MISS
QUIRK-SILVA- YOU MAY CLOSE. THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT RIGHT THEY GIVE UP SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWO ZERO SIX FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I'VE
DONE ALL I DALLY. DALLY EYEING
BENNETT. SENATE I CHEN LI LEAI
MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA
I HAVE FIVE OF THOSE FIVE ALSO
IS OUT VETERANS WITH THAT MR
GARCIA. NO MISTER CUNNINGHAM SO
. YOU MAY PERCEIVE ALREADY MISS
GARCIA. I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
PERSONA SORT OF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND THANK
YOURSELF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE BILL AND THE BILL OF.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO FOLLOW CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE APPROVING
AND BUILDING A NEW SCHOOL
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO MEET
THE SAME IS SAID. FIGHTING
REQUIRED IN THIS PUBLIC SCHOOLS
BEFORE BUILDING A NEW SCHOOL
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY TRYING TO
CREATE EQUITY TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OVER TO THE ARE SO. THAT THE
TYPE OF THEY ARE IN. BOTH ARE
CASES IN POINT A RISK THAT THE-
IN A POTENTIALLY UNSAFE. YOUR
SOURCES OF HOUSE IMAGE. SAID OR
WASTE OR LITERALLY ON TOP OF A
TOXIC SITE THAT HAS NOT BEEN
CLEANED UP. FOR EXAMPLE IN
FREMONT A PRIVATE SCHOOL IS
BUILT RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO A
CEMENT PLANT EXPOSING CHILDREN
AND STAFF TO HARMFUL OR TOXINS.
IN MY OWN BACKYARD AND CUT A HEY
THEIR PLANS TO BUILD. INTEREST
WILL ALLOW AND THAT IS TOXIC
SUBSTANCES INCLUDING LEAD AND
ARSENIC. COMMUNITY GROUP FILED A
LAWSUIT ON THE SUCCESSFUL IN
STOPPING THE CONSTRUCTION UNTIL-
UNTIL FEET. A FULL MITIGATION IS
COMPLETED. THIS IS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE A CRIME IN FOR BILLION
CHARTERS AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE
LESS RESTRICTIVE THAN THOSE FOR
STATE FUNDED SCHOOLS. ALLEN APPS
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. GREAT THANK YOU I
YOUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT WE ARE
WITNESS HERE IN SUPPORT. SOMEONE
FROM A WORLD WHERE THEY FROM. A
BAY AREA AND QUALITY MANAGEMENT
NO. BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT. WE'RE WAITING FOR
YOU. GOOD JOB. THIS IS WHY I RUN
IN MY SPARE TIME SORRY ABOUT
THAT AND- GERMAN DONNELLA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
ALLEN ABS THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICER WITH BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
SPONSOR BABY TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN. WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH IN CURRENT LAW
PRIOR TO CONSTRUCTING A NEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHARTER SCHOOL SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM SEVERAL ACTS OF DUE
DILIGENCE. TO BETTER IT. FUTURE
STUDENTS BERMAN AT THE PROPERTY
TO BE BUILT ON IS NOT A CURRENT
OR FORMER HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE
OR HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES RELEASE
SITE AND THEY CONSULT WITH STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES MAKE A
FINDING THAT THE HEALTH RISKS OR
OTHER POLLUTION SOURCES DO NOT
AND WILL NOT CONSTITUTE AN
ACTUAL OR POTENTIAL ENDANGERMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO PERSONS WHO
ATTACKED HER BE EMPLOYED AT THE
SCHOOL. THIS INCLUDES WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICTS. TO IDENTIFY
BOTH PERMITTED AND NON PERMITTED
FACILITIES WITHIN THAT DISTRICTS
ALREADY. INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO FREEWAYS AND OTHER
BUSY TRAFFIC CORRIDORS. LARGE
TRUE OPERATIONS RAILYARDS. AND
OTHER SOURCES WITH THE ONE
FOURTH OF A MILE OF THE PROPOSED
SCHOOL SITE. THIS IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY A PROP APPLIED TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS. AND SOME
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WHILE WE'RE
NOT CLAIMING THAT A LARGE NUMBER
OF THE SCHOOLS. ARE POORLY CITED
INCREASING LAND USE DENSITY AND
RE PURPOSING INFILL SITES.
RAISES THE POSSIBILITY THAT
WITHOUT SIMILAR DILIGENCE FUTURE
SCHOOLS CONSTRUCT. THE VICINITY
OF POLLUTION SOURCES THAT
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSE CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES TO UNHEALTHY
WORK ENVIRONMENT EIGHT TWENTY
TWO FOURTEEN. REQUIRES THE
SCHOOL AUTHORITIES TO ASSESS THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND AIR
POLLUTION CONDITIONS. ON IT IF
IT'S IN A- POSTAL TO KNOWLEDGE
THIS INFORMATION IF NECESSARY TO
USE IT. IN THEIR DECISION MAKING
PROCESS WHEN CONSTRUCTING THEIR
SCHOOL. ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA AQ INDIA AGAIN THANK.
MEMBERS ARE SEE A FOR OFFERING
THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY I
FOR YOUR VOTE. THAT AT. THIS IS. PLANT FOR THE SAN DIEGANS OF.
HI FINANCING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
COMPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY MY
NAME IS MERRY GRACE HOOLAHAN AND
I'M A CHECK DIRECTOR WITH
PACIFIC- SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF PCS D. AND
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN. PTSD IS NONPROFIT
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR TO
ADDRESS THE SINGLE GREATEST
HURDLE THAT FACE URBAN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THAT'S TO SECURE
ADEQUATE FACILITIES MY THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AS A
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LAND MANTISSA
NEAR LAND SURVEYOR FORMER PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR THE CURRENT PLAN
COMMISSIONER PROVIDE ME A
SIGNIFICANT UNDERSTANDING OF THE
- AND- TO. THE STATE IMPACTS
RESULT BURKE. TO SEE
REQUIREMENTS- PRIVATE SCHOOLS
ARE SAID TO A- LOCAL AGENCY
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENTITLEMENT AND
PERMITTING WHICH INCLUDE PUBLIC
REVIEW AND COMMENT. THE PROCESS
RESULT IN SAFE PROJECTS THAT
ADDRESS LOCAL COMMUNITY CONCERNS
IN AB TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN.
CHANGES TO THIS PROCESS CONFLICT
WITH LOCAL MUNICIPAL CODES AND I
DUPLICATIVE STATE LEVEL PROJECT
REVIEWS THESE REDUNDANT
REQUIREMENTS. WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE PROJECT COSTS AND
TIMELINES AKING AN ALREADY
DIFFICULT PROCESS EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING AND- AGENCY. IF
ENACTED THIS WOULD HAVE VERY
BILL IMPACTS CURRENT PCS
PROJECTS FOR EXAMPLE. THE
TECHNICAL HIGH SCHOOL WHICH IS
INITIATED THE END THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS TO DEVELOP A
PERMANENT HOME FOR THEIR SCHOOL
. LOCATION THIS IN TWENTY ONE
YEARS. THIS DO POP IS MORE THAN
EIGHTY NINE PER MEN UNDERSERVED
AND THE GRADUATION RATE IS ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. THE PROJECT
ENTITLEMENT INCLUDE SEQUENCE FOR
MENTAL ASSESSMENT AND SUCCESSFUL
REDEVELOPMENT WILL BRING THIS
FACILITY BACK TO LIFE BENEFITING
THE COMMUNITY WELL AS STUDENTS
AB TWENTY TWO FOURTEENTHS NEW
REQUIREMENTS EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST WILL COST DELAY INCREASED
US IN THIS. ALL I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
AN I'M HAPPY ANY. THANK YOU
THANK. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. I SEE NO OTHER
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM WILL
BRING IT BACK. TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS RATHER COMMIT
MISTER LEE. DR A MICROPHONE. THE
REASON YOU REPURPOSE THE
MICROPHONE THINKERS THREE
SILENCING ME YEAH. YES I WAS THE
FIRST TIME. SO I JUST WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR OBVIOUSLY
LEADING ON THIS BILL THIS WAS
THE DAY ALMOST SIMILAR BILL THAT
I BROUGHT TO THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR AND FORCING STOPPED IN THE
SENATE SO I'M REALLY GLAD TO BE
JOINED ALTERING WITH US AND
WE'RE GONNA SEE AND WE'RE
PICKING UP THE PIECES AGAIN- YOU
KNOW THE ANSWER THAT. WITH THE-
TWENTY MATT GRANDFATHERED IN NEW
DEVELOPMENTS AND WE STILL HAVE
THE OPPOSITION OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE SHE BECAUSE I
REMEMBER WHEN I RAN THE BILL
THEY WERE REALLY THE ONE THING
THEY WANTED TO DIE ON THE HILL
FOR WAS THE GRANDFATHER IN AND
NOW THE BILLS IN IT THEY'RE
STILL OPPOSED TO IT I STILL AM A
BIT CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE KIND
OF AMENDMENTS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL. IS HAVE THE IN THE
SCHOOL SETTING WITH ALL TYPES OF
SCHOOLS RIGHT WHETHER BE PRIVATE
CHARTER OR PUBLIC AND THIS IS
WHAT THE BILL IS TRYING TO DO
AND IF WE GIVE OUT LOOP CARVE
OUT LOOPHOLES OR CARBON
EXEMPTIONS FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
THIS OPENS THE DOOR FOR THOSE
KIND OF THINGS BUT I AM GLAD TO
BILLS MOVING FOR TODAY AND OF
COURSE VERY HAPPY THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING. GET A SORT OF. THANK
YOU MISTER LEE AND I THINK THE
BILL'S. ABOUT PARITY AND ACT. IN
THAT- THEY'RE TRYING TO BUY. THE
SAME RULES. AND GIVE. CLOSER TO
STUDENTS THE SAME ADVANTAGE OF
HAVING A CLEAN. SAFE CAMPUS.
WITH THAT. ANY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NO DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY MR LEE. AND THE-
SECOND. THE SECOND AYE MR
BENNETT- WOULD YOU CLOSER. I
YES. AT THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO. RESPOND TO. TO ONE THING-
SOME OF OUR MOST MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES- LIVE AND REALLY
TOXIC SPACES OUT THERE IN THIS
IDEA THAT IT'S OKAY TO BUILD ON
A SITE THAT WE KNOW HAS LEAD.
AND ARSENIC LIKE THE WE WERE
PROPOSING TO DO IN THE CITY OF
CREDIT HE MAKES NO SENSE TO ME
NO MATTER WHAT KIND OF SCHOOL.
YOU ARE OUT THERE SPECIALLY
GIVEN THE INFORMATION WE HAVE TO
DO HOW THAT AFFECTS A CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENT AND THEIR ABILITY TO
THINK ON AREN'T. OUT THERE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK ON THIS BILL AND I LOOK FOR
TO CREATING PARITY IN ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS TO HAVE A SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND- MAY CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. FILE ITEM NINE
AB TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE PROCESSED IN
THAT COMMITTEE. THE DONALD.
O'DONNELL I DALY DALLY NO
BENNETT BENNETT I CHEN LI LI I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I BY THE BILL HAS
FIVE OH TWO IS OUT THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO LOOKS LIKE
MOST RUBIO IS THE ONLY MEMBER
PRESENT WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN. FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT- ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO FIFTEEN TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE. STAFF AND THE CHAIR
FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE AND BY ACCEPTING THEIR
RECOMMENDED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS TO MANY
OF CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH GRADUATE
FROM CALL CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM SO THAT A WORKING
KNOWLEDGE OF BASIC FINANCIAL
SKILLS INCLUDING BUDGETING
BALANCING A CHECKBOOK IF THEY
EVEN KNOW WHAT A CHECKBOOK IT IS
AND BARRING CREDIT CARD USAGE
THE LACK OF BASIC FINANCIAL
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS OF YOUTH
TODAY IS. OF NATIONAL CONCERN
ARE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHICH
FAIL TESTS THAT EVALUATE THEIR
FINANCIAL KNOWLEDGE AND ARE
PREPARED BASE IMPORTANT
DECISIONS ABOUT BARRING SAY. IN
THE FINAL. BECAUSE OF THIS LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE TO MANY MAKE POOR
FINANCIAL DECISIONS AND FALL
INTO DEBT WHICH MAY TAKE THEM
YEARS TO RECOVER FROM AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTEEN WILL HELP ADDRESS
THIS GAP. LOCAL ODD KNOWLEDGE BY
CD TO DEVELOP RESOURCES FOR
INSTRUCTION AND FINANCIAL
LITERACY LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
ENTITIES NEED RESOURCES AND OUR
SUPPORT TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA'S
NEXT GENERATION WITH CRITICAL
LIFE SKILLS BEFORE THEY CAN MAKE
OF FINANCIALLY DAMAGING BEFORE
THEY MAY. ACTUALLY DAMAGING THE
STATE WITH IT WE HAVE A GAP-
WITH CALIFORNIA JUMPSTART
COALITION AS WELL AS FOR A JOB
FROM THE CALORIECOUNT AND-
ECONOMIC CASE. BY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU FOR THE SUB IS MY PLAY TO
REPRESENT CAL JUMPSTART COAL- WE
ARE A COALITION OF VOLUNTEERS
THAT ARE DEVOTED TO PROMOTING
PERSONAL FINANCE EDUCATION AND
HAVE BEEN DOING THAT FOR TWENTY
YEARS- I'M GOING TO APPRECIATE
THIS I GOT REALLY ENERGETIC BY
DOING ALL THIS BUT SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BROOKINGS
INSTITUTION ANALYSIS OF
FINANCIAL EDUCATION POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS FOUND THAT. THE LACK OF
BASIC TILL KNOWLEDGE WHEN USED
IS OF NATIONAL CONCERN AMERICAN
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ROUTINELY
FAIL TESTS THAT EVALUATE THEIR
pILL PREPARED TO FACE IMPORTANT
DECISIONS ABOUT BORROWING SAVING
INVESTING AND PLANNING FOR THEIR
FUTURES FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS-
THE JUMPSTART COALITION. HAS
PROMOTED THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERSONAL FINANCE EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- OUR
WEBSITE OR NEWSLETTER OR SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE OUR PARTNERS-
KEEP- EDUCATORS ADMINISTRATORS
PARENTS ANYONE INTERESTED IN.
PERSONAL FINANCE THE IMPORTANCE
OF PERSONAL FINANCE EDUCATED
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING. IN THAT
SPACE- IMPORTANT TO OUR MISSION-
IS. A FUNDING A GRANT FUNDED
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
NOW FOR SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.CALLED FINANCIAL
FOUNDATIONS FOR EDUCATORS IT'S A
WORKSHOP PROGRAM THAT IS
INTENDED TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR TEACHERS TO BE TAUGHT BY
EXPERTS. SENSUALES FINANCE
EDUCATION FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT.
BUT WE ALSO OF TRAIN THEM HOW TO
BE AN ADVOCATE IN THEIR SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES ARE DISTRICTS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHEREVER- AND
WE ALSO MAKE THEM AWARE OF THE-
MULTIPLICITY OF RESOURCES THAT
ARE OUT THERE FOR THEIR BENEFIT
SHOULD THEY- BE ABLE TO OR- ZIRE
- LET ME JUST SKIP THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU FOR ALL THIS TIME- SO
THE LATEST SURVEY OF. JUSTIN BY
THE COUNCIL ON ECONOMIC
EDUCATION. A CALIFORNIA STILL
STAYS IN THE BOTTOM OF THE PACK
WERE ONE OF ONLY FIVE STATES IT
DOESN'T HAVE A REQUIREMENT FOR
PERSONAL FINANCE EDUCATION- BUT-
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN I THINK
ADDRESSES IT WITHOUT IT BEING.
YOU KNOW A SPECIFIC REQUIREMENT
SO THAT WAS OF INTEREST TO US IN
OUR SUPPORT OF IT- YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE I'M SORRY SUMMARIZE
YES OKAY THANK YOU- SO IN
SUMMARY SOME OF MAY BE FAMILIAR
DR JIM. COOPER EMERITUS OF. CAL
STATES TO DINO I HE'S PROBABLY
BEEN BE THIS COMMITTEE A FEW
TIMES SO HE ASKED ME TO SHARE
THIS WITH YOU. IN HIS INIMITABLE
STYLE IT'S A NO BRAINER THAT
STUDENTS WHO UNDERSTAND PERSONAL
FINANCE WILL MAKE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS. ANSWER THEY CHIEF.
GOALS THIS IS GOOD FOR THE- AND
IT'S GOOD FOR THE ECONOMIC FINE
. FINANCIAL WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA. IT WON'T HAPPEN
WITHOUT STATE SUPPORT. PADDOCK
TO DO. THIS PROPOSAL. IS STARTED
THAT. WE NEED YOUR HELP. THANK
THANK BACK A- JONES ON OF TO
TEACH YOUR- CALL FOR COUNCIL ACT
. EDUCATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE SOCIAL STUDIES.
AND I CAN TELL YOUR TEACHERS ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HELP
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN THIS
REGARD THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT
MODEL PROGRAMS ARE OUT THERE
WHAT THEY CAN DO WHAT DISTRICTS
ARE DOING. SO STATE. IT'S FRIDAY
AND WE- THANK VERY MUCH THANK
YOU I IN SUPPORT. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
CASEY O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA WHO'S ALSO A CPA BY
TRADE VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT IN THE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU JERRY MEMBERS
MEMBER ASEAN HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETIES CPA'S IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS BRENDA
BASS ON THAT WITH THE YOU
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU I
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. C.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BRING
IT BACK BEHIND THE REAL I THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL THANK YOU FOR
THE EFFORT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT- YES HIGH SCHOOL
ECONOMICS TEACHER. RIGHT SPENT
HALF OF THAT CLASS DOING
FINANCIAL LITERACY TEACHING IT
TEACHING ONE OF FOUR THREE B.
WHAT'S A FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AN
IRA ROTH IRA IS ALL THOSE KINDS
. DIFFICULT GET. COGNEX AND IN
PEOPLE'S HEADS IT'S IT IS YOURS
I THINK THE- THEY KNOW ONE. KNOW
WHAT A DUMB FINANCE DECISION IS
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE WAS NOT
A SMART ONE IS RIGHT. WHEN WE
HAVE ALL BEEN A TON OF MONEY
WHEN WE WERE IN OUR EARLY
TWENTIES IN THE STOCK MARKET
REAL ESTATE HAD WE DO OVER
AGAIN- BUT EITHER WAY- BUT I
APPRECIATE THE BILL AND WHAT I
NEED IS TEACHERS I NEED
RESOURCES I DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED LESSON PLANS. I CAN FIGURE
THAT PART. BUT I NEED RESOURCES-
WEBSITE WHATEVER IT IS THAT I
CAN GO TO OR EVEN SOME. A
WEBSITE WITH A STUDENTS CAN GO
TO THEY CAN THEY CAN DO WE CAN
SHOW THEM COMPOUNDING INTEREST
WE CAN SHOW THEM THE ROLE OF
SEVENTY TWO. ALL THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. AREN'T IN FOR INSTANCE
FOR IN THEIR OWN SO IF THERE.
WERE PROGRAMS PORTALS ON THE ON
THE ON A WEBSITE WHERE THEY
COULD. YOU KNOW GOING OF THEIR
OWN FOR. THE WORLD- SOME STUFF
YOU COULD PRINT OFF TOO THAT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT PEOPLE ALWAYS
GET THAT- THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL VIDEOS ETCETERA. YOU
KNOW AND YOU KNOW THIS SIMPLE AS
AN INTERVIEW WITH A FINANCIAL%
PLANNER. RIGHT RIGHT. THAT THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE WHAT
TEACHERS NEED IN THE CLASSROOM.
THEY'LL DESIGN A LESSON. AT THE
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. REESE TO DO
IT THAT'S I NEED. AND I. THE
STUFF OKAY. THERE OKAY ADDED. I
PROBABLY LEARNED. BUT THOSE
FOLKS PROBABLY I'M SURE DO A LOT
BETTER IF THERE WAS ONE
RESOURCE. FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL RESOURCE- TO
CREATE THAT RESOURCE THAT BE A
GOOD THING. SO THAT AFFECTED ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF
COMMENT NO MANY US PLEDGES. HOLD
A YOUNG LEDGER. GROUPS AND WE DO
A FINANCIAL LITERACY AS PART OF
THAT AND I KNOW. I HAVE THIRTY
STUDENTS OR YOUNG INDIVIDUALS.
AND THEIR FAVORITE PART OF THE
PROGRAM IS THE FINANCIAL
LITERACY BECAUSE NOW THEY'VE
UPDATED IT SO MUCH THEY ACTUALLY
GIVE THEM. AN OUT TO LOG ON TO
IN FORTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THEN ASK THEM TO GO AHEAD
AND DO A BUDGET AND TO. DECIDE
HOW MUCH THEY'RE GOING TO PAY
FOR HOUSING AND THEY REALIZE AND
THEN. REALLY WITHIN FIVE TO TEN
MINUTES THAT THEY RAN OUT OF
MONEY PRETTY QUICKLY. SO IT'S
EXCELLENT- A WAY FOR THEM TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR PARENTS
ARE GOING THROUGH BUT ALSO THEIR
FUTURE BUDGETING THANK YOU FOR
A JOB. WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
MOVE BY MOVE VIRUS- QUIRK-SILVA
SECOND OF AYE MR BENNETT- WITH
THAT ARE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
JUST PULL IN ADDITION TO THAT I-
IN MY DISTRICT I SUPPORT A
PROGRAM CALLED MAD CITY MONEY
AND THERE'S A LOT COMPLAINTS TO
IT BUT THE HOW FOR THEM IS LIKE
WHAT I SPENT A HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH ON STARBUCKS. AND FOR THEM
WHEN THEY SEE THAT THE
ELECTRICITY BILL IS SIXTY THERE
LIKE WE SPEND MORE ON STARBUCKS
AND THE ELECTRICITY COSTS MY
POOR PARENTS ARE STRUGGLING SO
THAT THAT I CAN GET STARBUCKS
MANY SAID SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I WISH
THAT WE CAN EXPAND IT AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE THE
BEGINNING OF AN EXPANSION- IN
YEARS TO COME AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT. AND YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW THE RULES
SEVENTY TWO IS. MS RIVER. NOW
LOOK THAT UP SHE'S GONNA EDUCATE
. AND SO WITH THAT- CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. FILE ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
DONNA HI DALLI DALLI I'D
BENNETT. BENNETT I CHEN LI.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA HAI BY
BOTH IT IS FIVE ALSO IS UP THANK
YOU THINK IF. I MEAN STYLE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT THE
SPELLING. UNTIL WE NEED TO- FILE
ITEM FIVE ASSEMBLY- OWNERSHIP WE
NEED A MOTION ON FILE ITEM FIVE
. FILE ITEM FIVE. MISS
QUIRK-SILVA MAKES A MOTION
MISTER BENNETT WE SECOND YES
YEAH. SO HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FIVE FILE ITEM FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I DON'T
KNOW I DALLI. DALLI I'D BENNETT
BENNETT I CHEN. LI MCCARTY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA AYE I
MCCARTY I HAVE FIBER SO THAT
BILLS OFF I'M FIVE IS OUT WE'RE
NOT GONNA GO TOFILE ITEM
SIXTEEN BY MS DOLLY MISTER ALI
FILE I'M SIXTEEN AVOID MUMBLE
GOOD MISTER BLOOM. IT WILL WILL
BE WILL BE NICE LET HIM GO HE
WALKED AND- YOU TAKE THAT WITH
HIM TOMORROW. CLARK MISTER BLOOM
YOU MAY PROCEED WE'RE GONNA GO
WITH A FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
THIRTEEN AND IT MIGHT WHEN READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC CASE THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENT TEACHER AND STAFF MEMBER
. AT ULTIMATELY HAS ACCESS TO
FREE SAFE AND APPEALING DRINKING
WATER BY REQUIRING THE
INSTALLATION OF WATER BOTTLE
FILLING STATIONS IN SCHOOLS THAT
ARE EASILY ACCESSIBLE. LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKS COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THE BILL. I AM BRINGING THIS
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY BECAUSE
SIMPLY- BUT QUITE SIMPLY
CHILDREN ARE NOT CONSUMING THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THEY NEED. TO BE
HEALTHY. A 200-092-2012 NATIONAL
SURVEY FOUND THAT ONE IN TWO
CHILDREN AGE SIX TO NINETEEN IN
THE U. S. AT THAT TIME WERE NOT
ADEQUATELY HYDRATED WITH
DISPARITIES BY RACE AND GENDER.
THINGS HAVEN'T GOTTEN BETTER ON
A GIVEN DAY CHILDREN WHO DO NOT
DRINK ANY WATER CONSUME TWICE
THE CALORIES FROM SUGARY DRINKS
WHEN COMPARED TO CHILDREN WHO
DRINK WATER. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
41% OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN FROM
TWO TO ELEVEN YEARS OF AGE AND
62% OF CALIFORNIA TEENS FROM%
TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN. CONSUME
SUGARY DRINKS DAILY AND FOR
EVERY ADDITIONAL SERVING OF
SWEETENED BEVERAGES THAT A CHILD
CONSUMES PER DAY THE LIKELIHOOD
OF THE CHILD BECOMING OBESE
INCREASES BY 60% CONSUMPTION OF
IS LINKED TO CHRONIC DISEASES
SUCH AS TYPE TWO DIABETES AND
HEART DISEASE AND AS A RISK
FACTOR FOR DENTAL CARIES AND WE
KNOW THAT- OBESITY HAS BEEN
IMPLICATED AS ONE OF THE GREAT
ISSUES- THAT ARE IN EXISTING
INVOLVED AND INVOLVED WITH- THE
COVERT PANDEMIC. FOR SOME
CHILDREN SCHOOL MAY BE THE MOST
RELIABLE SOURCE OF SAFE AND
APPEALING DRINKING WATER
HOWEVER. ACCORDING TO A CHOICES
LEARNING COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIP REPORT EXAMINING
STRATEGIES TO PROVIDE IMPROVE
ACCESS TO DRINKING WATER IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ONE IN TEN
SCHOOLS REPORTED HAVING. NO
ACCESS TO FREE DRINKING WATER
WHERE MEALS ARE SERVED DESPITE
STATE AND FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE ADDITIONALLY
ONLY ONE IN FIVE SCHOOLS
REPORTED MEETING CRITERIA
CONSIDERED THE STANDARD FOR
EXCELLENCE IN WATER ACTS ACCESS.
DRINKING WATER BENEFITS
CHILDREN'S HEALTH IT'S THAT
SIMPLE IT HELPS CHILDREN.
DEVELOP STRONG MUSCLES JOINTS
AND TISSUE AND IMPROVES THEIR
DIGESTIVE SYSTEM KEEPS OUR
BODIES HYDRATED. DRINKING WATER
CAN ALSO POSITIVELY IMPACT
CHILDREN'S COGNITIVE PERFORMANCE
PARTICULARLY THEIR SHORT TERM
MEMORY ON AVERAGE KIDS DRINK
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR OUNCES OF
WATER DIRECTLY FROM WATER
FOUNTAIN THAT'S ABOUT THE SIZE
OF A CONDIMENT COP. IN SCHOOLS
WHERE KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO WATER
BOTTLE FILLING STATIONS THEIR
WATER INTAKE CAN INCREASE BY AS
MUCH AS TRIPLE. INCREASE ACCESS
TO FREE SAFE AND APPEALING
DRINKING WATER LEADS TO INCREASE
CONSUMPTION WHICH HAS NUMEROUS
PROVEN HEALTH BENEFITS LEADS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
HELPS IMPROVE STUDENTS
PERFORMANCE IN THE CLASSROOM. SO
EARLY PROMOTION AND EDUCATION ON
THE BENEFITS OF CONSUMPTION OF
WATER CAN HAVE POSITIVE LIFELONG
IMPACTS ENGAGING IN THIS TYPE OF
INTERVENTION IN THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SETTING AS AN AND DOT
IDEAL I ENVIRONMENT TO ENCOURAGE
THIS CRITICAL BEHAVIOR CHANGE
NINE PLEASED TO BE JOINED TODAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST BY LARA
SAID TRAN A TEACHER IN THE TWIN
RIVERS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND DOCTOR AND NISHA PATEL A
PEDIATRICIAN AND ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF PEDIATRICS AT
STANFORD TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU TO YOUR
FIRST WITNESS. RIGHT THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR A TESTIMONY TODAY MY NAME IS
DOCTOR NEED TO PATEL AS
MENTIONED I'M A PEDIATRICIAN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
PEDIATRICS AT STANFORD. I HAVE
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
CONDUCTING RESEARCH ON CHRONIC
DISEASE PREVENTION AMONG
CHILDREN WITH PARTICULAR
EXPERTISE ON DRINKING WATER IN
SCHOOLS. I'M TODAY I'LL TELL YOU
THREE REASONS WHY I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL FOR CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND
LEARNING. FIRST I'M TO PROMOTE
HEALTH WE WANT STUDENTS TO DRINK
WATER NOT SUGARY DRINKS. WE KNOW
THAT DRINKING WATER INSTEAD OF
SUGARY BEVERAGES CAN HELP TO
DECREASE OBESITY AS WELL AS
PREVENT DENTAL CARIES. AND
EITHER TWO OF THE MOST COMMON
CHRONIC CONDITIONS AMONG YOUNG
CHILDREN. BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
36% OF STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
WERE OVERWEIGHT TENNIS IS
INCREASE OF STAND TO LEAD A 46%
OVER THE PANDEMIC PERIOD. I'M
THIS IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
TO ADDRESS IN ADDITION WE KNOW
THAT PROVIDING WATER TO STUDENTS
IMPROVE THEIR COGNITION. WHICH
IS IMPORTANT FOR LEARNING.
SECOND CHILDREN SPEND
SUBSTANTIAL TIME IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS. WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN
PARTICULARLY THOSE OF COLOR
UNDER HYDRATED. IN A STUDY OF
LOS ANGELES STUDENTS WE FOUND
THAT SIXTY THREE PERCENT. OF
STUDENTS WERE UNDER HYDRATED AND
WE KNOW THAT WATER FOUNTAINS
WHEN THEY ARE ACCESSIBLE
STUDENTS DON'T USE THEM. IN OUR
STUDIES 326% OF STUDENTS WERE
USING- CONTENTS AT SCHOOLS. AT
LUNCH OR EVERY SAYS IT WILL BE
INSTALL THESE WATER BOTTLE
FILLING STATIONS. THEY ACTUALLY
PROMOTE INCREASED WATER INTAKE
AMONG STUDENTS. WE HAVE ONE
STUDY COULD THAT WE JUST
COMPLETED ACTUALLY. IN BAY AREA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AND THIS WAS
A STUDY. THAT WAS CONDUCTED IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND
WHAT WE FOUND IN THAT STUDY WAS
THAT. IN SCHOOLS FOR STUDENTS
HAD ACCESS TO NEWLY INSTALLED
WATER STATIONS. THEIR ODDS OF
BEING OVERWEIGHT REDUCED BY
SEVENTY PERCENT. SO IN SOME I
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION. BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
FOR CHILD HEALTH AND LEARNING.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
LAURA SATCHER AND I'M HERE TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY EIGHT. THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO ME NOT ONLY BECAUSE
I'M A HEART PATIENT- BUT I'M
ALSO A MOTHER AND AN EDUCATOR. I
TAUGHT GRADES K. EIGHT TO NINE
SINCE THE EARLY NINETIES AND
HAVE DEDICATED YEARS TO WORKING
WITH CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED
POPULATION. AND WITNESSED
FIRSTHAND THE STRUGGLE TO GET
PROPER HYDRATION INTO THE SCHOOL
SETTING. I'M CURRENTLY WORKING
AS A TEACHER ON A SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT IN THE TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. IN THIS
ROLE I WORK WITH ARE MOST
STRUGGLING SCHOOLS AND I'M
CURRENTLY SERVING THE STUDENTS
AT TWO OF OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS
. THE PURPOSE OF MY POSITION IS
NOT ONLY TO RAISE GRADES ACROSS
THE CURRICULUM. BUT TO RAISE
TEST SCORES IMPROVE READING
LEVELS SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH
THEIR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
REDUCE ABSENCES SUSPENSIONS. AND
EXPULSIONS. IT WOULD BE IDEAL IF
MY JOB IS AN EDUCATOR OR TO
SIMPLY FOCUS FOCUS ENTIRELY ON
THE ACADEMIC SIDE OF EDUCATION.
BUT OUR STUDENTS COME TO SCHOOL
WITH NEEDS FAR GREATER THAN JUST
THEIR ACADEMICS. ENSURING OUR
STUDENTS ARE IN THE BEST MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL SPACE THEY CAN BE
ONCE THEY ENTER OUR BUILDINGS IS
IMPERATIVE. ENSURING THEY HAVE.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT
THE DAY WHILE ON OUR CAMPUSES IS
AT THE VERY BASIC LEVEL OF
STUDENT NEEDS. MANY OF OUR
CAMPUSES UTILIZE PORTABLES TO
PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL SPACES FOR
STUDENTS WHICH ARE NOT EQUIPPED
WITH RUNNING WATER. THIS FORCES
STUDENTS TO LEAVE THEIR LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT TO MEET THE BASIC
NEEDS OF HYDRATION.
UNFORTUNATELY ACCESS TO WATER IS
NOT ALWAYS AVAILABLE MANY OF OUR
DRINKING FOUNTAINS ARE CAPPED
OFF INDUSTRY PAYER OR SIMPLY NOT
AVAILABLE. WHEN CHILDREN HAVE
CONTINUED ACCESS TO WATER
THEY'RE ABLE TO FOCUS LISTEN
COLLABORATE WITH PEERS RETRAIN
RETAIN INFORMATION AND INCREASE
ATTENTION SPANS. FOR HYDRATION
IS ESSENTIAL SOURCE STUDENTS CAN
PROPERLY FUNCTION LEARN AND
THRIVE. THIS BILL WILL HAVE A
GREAT IMPACT ON STUDENT HEALTH
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL STUDENTS TO INCLUDE OUR
NEEDIEST OF SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I URGE YOUTO SAY I
VOTE IN THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT MAY
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
MISSION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE.
THE MICROPHONE. YOU TURN MEMBERS
NICOLE KOREAN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
VOICE SUPPORT OF HEAL THE BAY
AND THE CLEAN THESE LOBBYING
COALITION. THANK YOU MAY PULL
THAT MICROPHONE DOWN. THANK YOU.
FOR SO HE DOESN'T HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. A PLATE DOWN TO- JAMIE
MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR THE BELL
AND- ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE I
TODAY. STACEY FOR PRO PRINCIPLE
GARDEN VALLEY ELEMENTARY IN THE
TWIN RIVERS SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I URGE YOU HI TO VOTE YES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. A SENIOR OPPOSITION
WILL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MR MCCARTY IS IT A MINUTE NOW
I'M OF THE BILL AND MOVED TO
HAVE A SECOND ROW. MISTER
BENNETT SECONDS MR YEAH AND THEN
YOU KNOW THANK MISTER BLOOM I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN ON THESE ISSUES
FROM. YOU KNOW A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS A YOU
KNOW PLASTIC BOTTLE PERSPECTIVE
EMBARRASSED SO THEY HAVE A
PLASTIC BOTTLE HERE. AND NOT MY
HYDRO FLASK HERE. BUT LOOK IF
YOU LOOK AT- THE ISSUE OF
OBESITY IN KIDS AT SCHOOL IS A
BIG FACTOR IN YEARS AGO WE HAD.
LITERALLY SODA MACHINES IN
SCHOOLS WE HAD COKE WHICH
SPONSORED THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
GET A LOT. TO REMOVE SUGAR
SWEETENED DRINKS FROM THE-
SCHOOL SITEWE HAVEN'T ALWAYS
BEEN EASY FOR KIDS TO DRINK THE
EASIEST AND CHEAPEST AND MOST
BENEFICIAL PRODUCT WHICH IS
WATER IN SELMA I THINK THIS IS
BECAUSE- THAT THE RIGHT BALANCE
HERE AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS FOR TEN YEARS
MISTER BROWN. THANK MAKE SURE
YOU RE USE THAT BOTTLE- BUT THAT
WE HAD WE DO HAVE MOTION A
SECOND I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANY MORE COMMENTS FROM INTO THE
COMMITTEE YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
MAKE SACRAMENTO CONROE PLEASED.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE PROCESSED IN
THAT COMMITTEE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I'D DALLY. DALLY I'D
BENNETT BENNETT I'D CHEN LI
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA FIVE
FIVE OF LAWS FIVE ALSO IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU JESSICA.
THAT WILL MOVE TO A MISTER
CUNNINGHAM WHO IS HERE MR COUNTY
HAS AB. TWO ZERO FIVE ONE. TWO
ZERO FIVE ONE. MY YES THEY WHEN
READING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO START WITH
THE HARD THANKS THE CHAIR AND TO
THE CA WE'VE BEEN WORK ON THIS
FINANCIAL LITERACY PIECE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND I THINK
WE'VE GOT SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
BE PROUD OF HERE- AB TWENTY
FIFTY ONE DIRECTS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
THE PURCHASE OF MATERIALS AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
MATERIALS NEEDED TO ADMINISTER
FINANCIAL LITERACY CLASSES.
CALIFORNIA REP AMONG THE WORST
STATES IN THE NATION FOR
FINANCIAL LITERACY INSTRUCTION
IN A RECENT REPORT BY THE CENTER
FOR FINANCIAL LITERACY AT
CHAMPLAIN COLLEGE IN VERMONT WE
ACTUALLY SCORED ENOUGH.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT WITHIN OUR
CURRICULUM TO COMPLETE FINANCIAL
LITERACY COURSE. OR A FINANCIAL
LITERACY COURSE IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL NOW.
MANY MANY HIGH SCHOOLS I SHOULD
NOTE DO INCORPORATE FINANCIAL
LITERACY AS PART OF AN ECONOMICS
CLASS ARE PART OF A CIVICS CLASS
SO THAT IS A GOOD THING- BUT
THEY NEED SOME HELP. NEED SOME
HELP BECAUSE UNDERSTANDING THE
BASICS OF MONEY AND HOW MONEY
WORKS INTEREST RATES HOW
INTEREST RATES WORK BOTH FOR YOU
IN THE INVESTMENT CONTACTS AND
AGAINST YOU AND IN THAT CONTEXT
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO BALANCE
CHECKBOOK UNDERSTAND THE TIME
VALUE OF MONEY. UNDERSTANDING
CERTAIN BASIC THINGS ABOUT
CREDIT AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
CREDIT REPORTING IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN A GOOD CREDIT SCORE TO
BUY A HOME OR MONEY TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND DO THOSE THINGS. WE
ALL WANT OUR KIDS TO STRIVE TO
DO- THOSE ARE BASIC LIFE SKILLS
IN MY VIEW IT'S SIMILAR TO
HEALTH CLASS IN BASIC NUTRITION
TO BASE MATHEMATICS TO BE ABLE
TO READ WRITE. FACT BILLION. SO
FORTH. SO I THINK IT'S REALLY I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD. WAY TO DO
IT BECAUSE IF WE CAN GET MONEY
APPROPRIATED AT WHETHER IT'S
THIS YEAR OR IN THE FUTURE YEAR
THAN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
BE INCREASING THE POP THE-
INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF FUNDS
THAT CAN BE USED. AND IT'S A
VERY SMALL INVESTMENT IN TERMS
OF DOLLAR TERMS BUT- IN TERMS OF
THE WAY CAN CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES I CAN TELL. YOU KNOW I.
SCHOOL LONG TIME. YEAH YOUR
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND- WITH A
LAW SCHOOL I'D I KNOW A LOT OF
LAWYERS AND A LOT OF DOCTORS FOR
YOU KNOW WE ALL DO. THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO GO TO A LOT OF
EDUCATE GO THROUGH A LOT OF
EDUCATION ARE VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE. THE DON'T
KNOW THE FIRST THING ABOUT HOW.
TO MANAGE MONEY. AND IT DIDN'T
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER YOU'RE
MAKING FIFTY THOUSAND A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IF
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND BASICS. OF
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT BASICS OF.
ALL THE THINGS I MENTIONED
EARLIER- HE E. ARE GOING TO HAVE
LESS SUCCESS IN LIFE MORE STRESS
IN LIFE ANDYOU OTHER WILL. PUT
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING ALL OUR
KIDS. IN THE EARLIER WE GET THAT
EDUCATION. IN THE SYSTEM THAT
EARLIER WE EXPOSE KIDS THESE
CONCEPTS- THE BETTER POSITION
THEY ARE TO SUCCEED IN LIFE. I
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TEN RENTS AT A OF
NEXT GEN PERSONAL FINANCE. THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBER. THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY. IS
A POPULAR ME. TODAY ARE SOCIAL.
GO SOME LIKE THE- THINGS I NEVER
LEARNED IN HIGH SCHOOL INCLUDES
A LIST OF ITEMS LIKE TAXES
BANKING MANAGING MONEY HOW TO
INTERVIEW AND IT ENDS WITH THIS
. I SURE AM GLAD THAT I LEARNED
THE PERFECT RIAN THEOREM. IT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT CLASS YOU
NEVER HAD. IT'S A CLASS THAT
RESEARCH SHOWS IMPROVES LIVES BY
HELPING PEOPLE MANAGE CREDIT
HELPING THEM STAY OUT OF THINGS
LIKE HIGH INTEREST LOANS HELP
THEM MANAGE STUDENT LOANS YOU
KNOW STUDENT DEBT IN THIS
COUNTRY IS BUT ONE POINT EIGHT
TRILLION DOLLARS. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DID SOME
RESEARCH WE FOUND 88% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS SAID THEY
SHOULD BE A GUARANTEE PART. OF
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION. NOT ONLY
DID THEY SAY THAT THAT WAS
IMPORTANT HE SAID IT'S URGENT.
THAT LEGISLATORS ACT UPON IT.
SOME TALK ABOUT HIGH SCHOOL
PERSONAL FINANCE COURSES TODAY.
ONLY TWENTY FIVE YOU HEARD THAT
CALIFORNIA GOT AN F. IN THAT
CHAMPLAIN COLLEGE STUDY WE FOUND
ONLY 25% OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO A
PERSONAL FINANCE ELECTIVE. TO
NOT A GUARANTEE JUST ELECTIVE
NATIONWIDE THAT NUMBER 70% SO WE
ARE WHEN WE RANK IN OUR ANNUAL
STUDY WHEN WE READ CALIFORNIA'S
FORTY NINTH AT A FIFTY. AND THE
STATE CAN DO BETTER. SO MY NAME
IS TIM RAINES I'M CO FOUNDER OF
NEXT GEN PERSONAL FINANCE WE'RE
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT WHERE
THE LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING CURRICULUM AS WELL AS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
EDUCATORS COOL THING ABOUT OUR
BUSINESS MODELS EVERYTHING WE
WAS FREE. SO I HAD SOME SUCCESS
AS AN ENTREPRENEUR INVESTOR AND
I CREATED ENDOWMENT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN OUR MISSION AS AN
ORGANIZATION EVERY STUDENT
DESERVES TO TAKE A PERSONAL
FINANCE COURSE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM LEARN FOR
THE SCHOOL OF HARD KNOCKS. SO
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE WE WORK WITH
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA OVER
THIRTY NINE HUNDRED CURRENTLY
USE OUR CURRICULUM SO IT'S
HAPPENING. IT'S JUST NOT
HAPPENING ENOUGH RIGHT THAT TWO
UNITS IN ECONOMICS PROBABLY.
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO GET THROUGH
THE MATERIAL YOU SHOULD. BUT
THERE ARE SOME AMAZING EDUCATORS
IN CALIFORNIA LET ME LET ME
POINT OUT ONE HER NAME IS TARA
ROS HE- TEACHES AT SAN MARCOS.
EXCUSE ME SAN MARCO HIGH SCHOOL
. SHE WAS INSPIRED TO START AN
ELECTIVE AND SHE THOUGHT YOU
KNOW I'M GONNA START ELECTED IN
THE FALL IN. WE WILL HAVE ONE
SECTION IN TWENTY STUDENTS. YOU
KNOW SHE'S ENDING THE YEAR WITH
SIX SECTIONS TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY STUDENTS THAT'S THE IN
BACK ALL SHE DID WAS SHE LED A
SPARK SHE SAID LET'S OFFER
ELECTIVE THIS CLASS IS IN DEMAND
AND I THINK WE BELIEVE IN THE
REASON I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIFTY ONE. IS THAT THIS
IS GONNA LIGHT MULTIPLE SPARKS
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU. CAN
JUST CLOSE WITH ONE ONE LAST
THING I THINK THIS IS THE GOOD
PART SO WHEN AB TWENTY FIFTY ONE
PASSES AND IS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE. I'M IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SO I HEARD YOU
EARLIER CHAIR DONAL SAY I WISH
THERE WAS A SITE THAT I COULD
HAVE GONE TO. THAT HAD
EVERYTHING. I STARTED MY
NONPROFIT EIGHT YEARS AGO TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND TEACHERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY CURRENTLY USE A SO.
THERE ISN'T A TON OF EFFORT TO
KIND OF GET THE BALL ROLLING
IT'S THERE. THIS FREE CURRICULUM
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WE
WILL COMMIT. MY ORGANIZATION AND
GPF WILL COMMIT TO MATCHING
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT UP TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION PLEASE
PLEASE PLEASE INVEST IN TEACHERS
THAT'S WHERE THE ALUE IS THANK
YOU THANK YOU JUST A QUESTION TO
SO DO YOU HAVE SUCH A WEBSITE
YEAH W. W. W. DOT N. G. P. F.
.ORG. THANK YOU. THANK. OKAY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. IT'S A-
BIGGER MEMBERS NOT BRASSY
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF CPA'S IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO OUR
MEMBERS CARSON NEED THEM HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS AND LEAD
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT MEAN LIKE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS BRENDA
BASS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION SEEING OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK ON AGAIN I
PUT UP TO SAY WHAT I SAID
EARLIER I APPRECIATE THIS
EFFORT. AS SOMEONE WHO TEACHES.
NO THIS VERY TOPIC IN AN
ECONOMICS CLASS SO THE ECONOMIC
CURRICULA. STANDARDS ARE NOT
THAT WIDE YOU CAN GET THEM DONE
AND ABOUT HALF OF THE SEMESTER
THEN YOU SPEND. THE REST OF THAT
SEMESTER TEACHING TO A LETTER
SEEN ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD JOB.
IN THAT TIME FOR YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY NEED A STANDALONE
CLASS THE PLACE FOR THIS TO GET
DONE IS IN. AN ECONOMICS CLASS
BUT AGAIN AS I SHARED YOU
HIGHLIGHTED I THINK TEACHERS
NEED RESOURCES PROBABLY NEED TO
BE EDUCATED THEMSELVES- ON THIS
TOPIC WHAT HAPPENS YOU BUY
STOCKS WHATEVER YOU BUY AN INDEX
FUND WHATEVER YOU BUY. YOU KNOW
IRAN AND YOU KNOW ROTH IRA
TRADITIONAL FOUR THREE BE ALL
THAT KIND OF STUFF. INVEST IN
PROPERTY ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF
HAS TO BE TUCKED IN. AND PEOPLE
NEED TOOLS TO TEACH THAT A BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF YOUR
HIGHLIGHTED TO- BUT ALSO TOOLS
TO TEACH THAT THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT I WOULD NEED. IN A
CLASSROOM IN A WAY THAT ENGAGES
STUDENTS NOW NOT JUST YOU KNOW
READ YOU GOT A LIMIT. RIGHT SO I
APPRECIATE THAT MR BENNETT.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH A MISTER
CHAIR. ON AFTER SPENDING MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS THE TEACHING
OF REQUIRED ECONOMICS COURSE. IN
HIGH SCHOOLS. I WOULD JUST OFFER
I COMPLETELY AGREE THAT EVERY
STUDENT NEEDS. MUCH MORE AND
BETTER. FINANCIAL LITERACY. AND
THE ECONOMICS COURSES THE PROPER
PLACE TO DO IT. I THINK THE
CHALLENGE IS. GETTING IT TO
HAPPEN IN THE- COMICS COURSE.
AND THAT IS WHERE I THINK WE
REALLY STILL NEED WORK. AND THAT
IS IT SHOULD NOT BE UP TO THE
TEACHER. WHETHER THEY ARE GOING
TO ARE NOT GOING TO TEACH THE
FINANCIAL LITERACY COMPONENTS.
THAT ARE SO ESSENTIAL FOR
CHILDREN TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND
RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT FRANKLY THAT
IS THE CASE. THERE IS NOT REALLY
A WAY FOR US TO ESTABLISH THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY. I KNOW SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT MMHM MANY
TEACHERS ARE RELUCTANT TO TEACH
GOVERNMENT AND SO WHAT THEY'VE
DONE IS THEY'VE TAKEN THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND ECONOMICS ONE
SEMESTER REQUIREMENT FOR REACH
AND THEY DO SO THREE QUARTERS OF
GOVERNMENT AND THEN TRY TO
SQUEEZE THE ECONOMICS IN AND ONE
QUARTER THEY DO THAT. PLACIDA
BUT AND SAY THAT'S THAT'S GOOD
ENOUGH AND WE NEED TO FIND A WAY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE READY MANDATE ECONOMICS THAT
WAS. THE BATTLE FOUGHT PEOPLE
THOUGHT THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR.
THIS LITERACY FOR STUDENTS BUT
IT IS NOT WHAT MANY TEACHERS
HAVE BEEN COMFORTABLE WITH AND
SO I THINK WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL HERE WHICH IS MAKE TEACHERS
MORE COMFORTABLE BUT THERE ALSO
NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT
THAT COMPONENT THE ECONOMICS
COURSE IS TAUGHT AND TAUGHT
WELL. IT IS. YOUNG PEOPLE FUTURE
SO ARE YOU KNOW LITERALLY CAN BE
RUINED BY THE TIME THEY'RE
TWENTY ONE OR TWENTY TWO. NUMBER
ONE.
AND IF YOUGET IN THE WRONG
HABITS IT IS REALLY HARD TO GET
OUT OF THAT HABIT OF- DOING THAT
SO THIS ISN'T. A BE ALL A CURE
ALL BUT IT IS AN ESSENTIAL FIRST
STEP TO GETTING FURTHER ALONG IN
SO THAT'S THE CHALLENGE THAT I
SEE THAT WE STILL HAVEN'T
CALIFORNIA WELCOME THE STAFF.
GRADUATING AND CAN. YOU FOR-
STEPPING UP- WITH FREE RESOURCES
FOR TEACHERS AND STUDENTS AND IF
I CAN JUST JUMP IN I THINK I
THINK THE VALUE OF THE COURSE
IS. THE ISSUE OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
BECAUSE IT IS EMBEDDED IN
ANOTHER COURSE IN HIS RESEARCH
OUT THERE THAT SUGGEST ABOUT
HALF THE TIME WHEN IT'S EMBEDDED
IN OTHER COURTS IS NOT TAUGHT.
RIGHT RIGHT IT MIGHT BE IN THE
STANDARDS BUT- MANY TEACHERS ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE ECONOMICS.
SO THAT EACH ECONOMICS AND-
THAT'S WHAT WE FIND AGAIN 70% OF
KIDS NATIONWIDE. ATTEND SCHOOL
THAT HAS AN ELECTIVE 25%
CALIFORNIA. I'M GONNA ON BOTH
YOU SAY THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROBLEM. THIS IS
THE DUTY OF A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATION. TO MAKE SURE
SCHOOLS ARE TEACHING WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO TEACH- THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO TEACH US IN
THEIR ECONOMICS COURSE. I THINK
IT MAY BE THAT PEOPLE AFRAID OF
IT BECAUSE MAYBE THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THEMSELVES AS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED OR MAYBE. THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO DO IT. OR
DO YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES ARE
THERE. THE RESOURCES ARE THERE
HEY YOU YOU TELL ME YOU GOT A
WEBSITE. OKAY I'LL BE MORE THAN
WEBSITE ON- UNTIL I GET THAT AND
I'M GONNA GO LOOK AT THIS
WEBSITE. BUT I WOULD SAY FOR ME
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER. I WAS
PRETTY MUCH DEVELOPING- I DIDN'T
RESOURCES YOU'RE SAYING THIS
ABOUT I APPRECIATE THAT'S GREAT
I'M GONNA GO TO THAT WEBSITE SO
I THINK AND IT MISTER CHAIRMAN
COULD I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
YOU ADMINISTRATORS THAT'S THAT
THEIR PRIMARY FUNCTION NOT TO BE
TO MAKE SURE TEACHERS ARE
TEACHING WELL AND TEACHING WITH
THEIR ASSIGNED TO IT AND THEN
PUT BUT WE ALL KNOW WAY TOO
OFTEN TEACHERS ARE COMPLETELY
LEFT- ON THAT ISSUE AND THEN
TEACHERS STILL HAVE TO MAKE THE
PROFESSIONALS OF ALL OF THE
PERKS OF ALSO. IT CLEARLY IS BUT
IT CLEARLY IS IMPORTANT WE GET
THIS DONE BETTER THANK YOU.
GREAT WITHOUT ANY FOR THE
COMPANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ARE
YOU DO ACCEPT THAT MANY MOMENTS.
YES SORRY AND THE COURTS OKAY
THAT- SO WITH THAT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE YOU CAN CLOSE
REAL QUICKLY. I'LL JUST BE VERY
BRIEF I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP BECAUSE- WHETHER
IT IS A RESOURCE ISSUE OR
WHETHER IT'S INTIMIDATION ISSUE
OR WHATEVER IT IS THAT THIS.
BILL AND- FUTURE FUNDING WE HOPE
TO GET WILL. ENABLE THOSE
TEACHERS THAT ARE READY TO DO
THIS WITHIN THEIR ECONOMICS
CURRICULUM- THE SOME TOOLS TO GO
OUT FIGURE OUT HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY DO IT AND GET OVER
HOPEFULLY. MAYBE THE IMITATION.
I'M MATT LIKES ME. RIGHT IN THIS
SOME PEOPLE ARE MATH BUT MOST
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE MATH. AND YOU
KNOW YOU'RE A KID SHOULD COME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL TODAY
KNOWING. IF I GET THROWN A
CREDIT CARD WHEN I GO TO COLLEGE
AND THEY SAY SIGN UP FOR THIS
CREDIT CARD WITH YOUR THREE
THOUSAND DOLLAR LIMIT. AND THEN
THEY PUT THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON A CREDIT CARD A 20% INTEREST
AND MAKE MINIMUM PAYMENTS. HOW
MUCH THEY ACTUALLY PAID OR
BANKING INTERESTS AND HOW LONG
IT'S GONNA TAKE THEM TO PAY THE-
MOST KIDS I WOULD. DO NOT UNDER
AND THAT AND WE'RE SENDING THEM
INTO THE WILD WITHOUT THE TOOLS
THEY NEED. SO I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS WORK ON THIS THANK YOU. I
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SECOND WE NEED A TICKET- WE NEED
A SECOND AGAIN SECOND MR MCCARTY
. AND DON. FILE ITEM SIX A. B.
TWO ZERO FIVE ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DONALD I DON'T
KNOW WHY DALLY. DELHIITES
BENNETT. AYE BENNETT AYE CHAN
LEE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA THE APARTMENT THE
HOUSE FOR A VOTE SO IT IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO- I AM SIXTEEN.
SIXTEEN. THAT'S AB TWO THREE SIX
FOUR HONEST ALI.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT CHAIRED
THE COMMITEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AND I WOULD WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR WOULD CREATE THE ROLE
EDUCATION TASK FORCE TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S SMALLEST RULE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS RECEIVE PROPER
RECOGNITION REPRESENTATION AND
GUIDANCE THAT THEY NEED. TO
FREQUENTLY SMALL RURAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE TREATED AS IF THEY
HAVE THE SAME ABILITY AND
RESOURCES AS LARGE URBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS A FORMER SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER IN A VERY SMALL
ROLE DISTRICTS I WAS OFTEN
PRESENTED WITH PROBLEMS UNLIKE
THOSE FACED BY LARGE URBAN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHEN POLICY IS
MADE BY OUR PUBLIC FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THERE'S GREAT
CONSIDERATION GRANTED FOR URBAN
AND SUBURBAN SCHOOLS. BUT THERE
IS RARELY MUCH ATTENTION PAID TO
ARE VERY RURAL SCHOOLS THE TASK
FORCE WILL PROVIDE VALUABLE
INPUT REGARDING THE IMPACT ON
RURAL SCHOOLS TO OUR STATE
POLICYMAKERS WHEN THEY'RE
CRAFTING LAW AND REGULATIONS. TO
HAVE DEDICATED EXPERTS SERVING A
REAL EDUCATION TASK FORCE WOULD
ALLOW FOR BETTER CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE STATE SMALL SCHOOLS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF IT. XIN
CREE THE ROLE. TASK FORCE WILL
PROVIDE A CRITICAL VOICE AND
EXPERTISE IN CALPERS MALLS
SCHOOLS WHICH HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS.
THIS IS IN KEEPING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S BELIEF
AND PURPOSE TO PROVIDE A WORLD
CLASS EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE IN TODAY WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOLS DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AS- BRETT SNYDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
. MR MEMBERS PARRIS MANNER AND
WE HAVE A SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION- SMALL DISTRICTS
REPRESENT ALMOST 60%OF THE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE IN A
THIRD OF THE MARS ARE RURAL AND-
FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES SOME OF
THOSE THINGS WERE RELATED TO
GEOGRAPHY WERE YOU HAVE STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS TRAVELING LONG
DISTANCES. YOU HAVE UNIX. IS YOU
OFTEN CAN'T COURSES LIKE
ADVANCED PLACEMENT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS- YOU SEE THAT MORE
AND THESE WERE IN THESE RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER PLACES-
AND FINALLY THEIR SMALL SO THEY
HAVE YOU KNOW SMALLER STAFF
CLASSIFIED STAFF TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS THAT THAT JUST
CREATES UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE AN
ADVISORY BODY TO THE STATE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ED AND HOPEFULLY
THAT TO THE STATE BOARD INTO YOU
ALL THE LEGISLATURE- AROUND SOME
HAS UNIQUE NEEDS AND GIVE YOU
SOME BETTER PERSPECTIVE AS
YOU'RE- CONSIDERING DIFFERENT
POLICY. CHANGES SO WE THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR CARRYING THE
BILL- WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OWNERS
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF YOU LIKE
THANK YOU. I ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. I'M FORTY SEEN ON ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SIGNOFF
POSITION WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I AM A COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW. IT'S ACTUALLY A MEDI
- SO WE WILL HOLD- HOLD WILL
HOLD A MEDIA MOTION UNTIL THERE
IS A CORE. SO. I'M SORRY OKAY I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. I GUESS I
GUESS IT WAS REMOVED ABOUT ON A
SECOND MY DOLLAR THERE WE GO
THAT ARE MATH. THAT WAS MATH
RIGHT THERE. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT- SO WE WILL WAIT TO- CALLED
CALLED COLOR. CHOLERA OKAY
BECAUSE- OKAY SURE YOU COULD
CLOSE SORRY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I DON'T
KNOW WHY DALLY. DALLY II BENNETT
CHEN LEAVE MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA
WE HAVE TO VOTE. BUST BENNETT
I'D WE HAD THREE VOTES SO IT IS
A IT IS ON CALL WITH THAT WILL
DO IS A GRAVE GABRIEL WAS HERE
IS HERE FO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN THAT'S AB TWENTY TWO.
EIGHTY FOUR.
DING YES GOOD. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
I WANT TO START OFF BY CCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE MEMINTA NO NOTHING
THE- COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE. I AM PLEASED TO BE
PRESENTING AB TWO TWO EIGHT FOUR
WHICH WOULD UPON APPROPRIATION.
INSTRUCT THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING FOR INSTRUCTION
MATERIALS AND FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IN DIGITAL AND MEDIA
LITERACY- YOUNG CALIFORNIA'S USE
OF THE INTERNET HAS ALLOWED FOR
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITIES
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. AND BUT
ALSO CARRIED WITH IT SOME
SIGNIFICANT RISKS INCLUDNG
CYBER BULLING MENTAL HEALTH
SAFETY AND SECURITY CONCERNS.
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
ALSO BECAUSE MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS
TO USE DIGITAL PLATFORMS TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION FURTHER
INTEGRATING DIGITAL MEDIA INTO
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. OUTSIDE
THE CLASSROOM THE USE OF DIGITAL
MEDIA HAS BECOME EXTREMELY
WIDESPREAD AND SO IN TURN HAVE
THE POTENTIAL PITFALLS WE HAD A
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO WHERE I WAS. AMAZED TO
LEARN THAT- POST PANDEMIC
TEENAGERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE SPENDING CLOSE TO
EIGHT HOURS A DAY ONLINE SO ONE
THIRD OF THEIR DAY ONLINE. A
RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT 59% OF
TEENS HAVE EXPERIENCED CYBER
BILLING AND ONLINE HARASSMENT.
THERE ARE OTHER CONCERNS OF
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF DIGITAL
MEDIA ON BODY IMAGE MENTAL
HEALTH. THE HAVE INCREASINGLY
ALARMING DIGITAL AND MEDIA
LITERACY EDUCATION IS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL TO COMBAT THESE
ISSUES AND IT TEACHES CHILDREN
HOW TO BE SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE
ONLINE HOW TO BE GOOD DIGITAL
CITIZENS THE INFORMATION COVERED
IN THIS EDUCATION ABOUT A VALUED
IN THE BUILDING OF ONLINE MEDIA
PROTECTING PRIVATE INFORMATION
UNDERSTANDING DIGITAL FOOTPRINTS
AND RESPECTING OTHERS ONLINE. AB
TWO TWO EIGHT FOUR SIX TO
FURTHER ENABLE TEACHERS AND
SCHOOLS TO INTEGRATE DIGITAL AND
MEDIA LITERACY IN. AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO HELP YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS SAFELY
pNAVIGATE THE DIGITAL WORLD. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN PERSON IS
MARVIN DION THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA POLICY AT
COMMONSENSE AND DYLAN HOFFMAN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU TO YOUR FIRST
WITNESS YOU. MORNING SHERIN
MEMBERS- I'M MARVIN BEYOND VICE
PRESIDENT OF- CALIFORNIA POLICY
A COMMONSENSE- AND- BEFORE I GET
STARTED I JUST WANTED TO SAY AB
I HEARD YOU MENTION THAT
TEACHERS NEED ONLINE RESOURCES
LIKE- VIDEOS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT CAN ACCESS AND COMMONSENSE
OFFERS A WELL. THOSE RESOURCES
IN THE THIRD OF THE NUMBER
RIGHT- AS I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC MAGNIFIED MANY NEW AND
LONGSTANDING VULNERABILITIES IN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM- S. K.
TWELVE WAS FORCED ON MINE ONE OF
THOSE- ISSUE THAT WAS LAID BARE
IS. THE USE DIGITAL DIVIDE WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONWIDE- IN A MAD SCRAMBLE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE LAWMAKERS
EDUCATORS PRIVATE INDUSTRY
PHILANTHROPY AND COMMUNITY-
BANDED TOGETHER IN AN AMAZING
EFFORT TO CONNECT MORE KIDS-
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA'S
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT OF OVER
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS A RESULT OF
THESE EFFORTS MANY KIDS AND
TEENS ARE NOW ON. AND WILL BE
CONNECTED TO THE VAST INTERNET-
THIS IS GIVING MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
ACCESS TO EXPLORE CONNECT CREATE
AND LEARN WAYS NEVER BEFORE
IMAGINED. UNFORTUNATELY ACCESS
HAS COME WITHOUT A SAFE
OPERATING MANUAL- WITH THIS VAST
POWER AND ACCESS COME ETHICAL
DILEMMAS DILEMMAS CHALLENGES
AND- OTHER THINGS THAT MUST BE
MANAGED INCLUDING. BULLYING HATE
SPEECH. IT IS TO MISINFORMATION
PRIVACY VIOLATIONS TECH
ADDICTION AND OTHER I'M SURE YOU
CAN IMAGINE ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES- THESE ISSUES ARE
INCREASINGLY FACED IN BOTH
SCHOOLS AND AT HOME. AS A RESULT
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH HOW TO MAKE
SENSE OF THIS NEW WORLD AND HOW
TO EMPOWER KIDS. TO USE
TECHNOLOGY RESPONSIBLY AND
SAFELY IN OTHER WORDS HOW TO BE
GOOD ONLINE CITIZENS- INCREASED
ACCESS TO ONLINE CONTENT HAS
ALSO BEEN LINKED TO SIGNIFICANT
UPTICKS IN TEAM SEEKING SUPPORT
FOR MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS. 69%
OF BLACK YOUTH IN 767% OF
HISPANIC LET MAKES YOU REPORT
OFTEN OR SOMETIMES EMPIRE
ENCOUNTERING BRACES CONTENT
ONLINE. 74% OF LGBTQ YOUTH OFTEN
. OR SOMETIMES ALSO INQUIRE
ENCOUNTER HOMOPHOBIC CONTENT ON
COUNT ON SOCIAL MEDIA. AND
SEVENTEEN YOU OFTEN OR SOMETIMES
ENCOUNTER SIX SEXIST OR BODY
SHAMING CONTENT. IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THESE TYPES OF CONCERNS
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH PROJECT
ZERO AT THE HARVARD SCHOOL-
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
COMMONSENSE IS RESEARCHED THESE
ISSUES AND DEVELOPED K. THROUGH
TWELVE CURRICULUM THAT'S
AVAILABLE ONLINE FREE OF CHARGE
TO EDUCATORS. WITH THESE FREE
OFFERINGS WE CURRENTLY REACH
OVER 60% OF U. S. STUDENTS AND
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK TO REACH A NEW GENERATION
OF STUDENTS. THERE'S A WITH WHAT
THEY EXPERIENCE ONLINE AND THIS
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
FACT ACCORDING TO A FUTURE OF
TECHNICIAN POLL RELEASED EARLIER
THIS YEAR 862% OF THOSE SURVEYED
INCLUDING REP REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS SUPPORT TEACHING
DIGITAL SET- AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL IN THIS COMMITTEE HAVE
WISELY WORKED TO IDENTIFY WAYS
TO STREAMLINE THE GRANT PROCESS
OF THIS BILL- WE ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CONNECT WITH US. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON HOFFMAN
WITH TACK NAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT- AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR- MORE
THAN EVER BEFORE CHILDREN TEENS-
INTERACT SOCIALLY- CREATE ART
AND MUSIC. AND CONNECT WITH THE
WIDER WORLD ACROSS BORDERS
CULTURES AND LANGUAGES ALL
ONLINE- BUT FOR ALL THESE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE MANY
RISKS. IN ADDITION A GROWING
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS HAVE
TRANSITION TO ONLINE EDUCATION
MAKING STOOD INCREASE. I
INTERNET ACCESS. IS AN ONLINE
PLATFORMS TO ACCESS EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS. IN ORDER FOR CHILDREN
SAFELY NAVIGATE AND INTERACT-
WITH THIS INFORMATION IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE. ESPECIALLY AS TO WHAT
IS AND ISN'T REAL HOW TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST RISKS AND HOW
TO. TREAT OTHERS ONLINE
UNFORTUNATELY MANY SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY LACK THE
RESOURCES NEEDED PROVIDED- AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR DRESSES
THIS NEED- THIS BILL WILL NOT
ONLY. BUT ALSO PROMOTE THE SHARE
BEST PRACTICES AND MAKES DIGITAL
AND MEDIA LITERACY. VERY OPEN
KITCHEN. FOR THESE REASONS TECH
THAT STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. SEENU OTHERS IN THE
ROOM AND SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THE NEW OPPOSITION
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN I WAS MAKE COMMENTS ABOUT.
LONG LINES OF THE FINANCIAL
COMMENTS AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
WHAT I NEED. TO HELP MY STUDENTS
ARE RESOURCES RIGHT YOU SAID
COMMON. SENSE HAS THAT THEY HAVE
A WEBSITE THAT'S GREAT- BUT
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE TOOLS
THAT. BUT STUDENTS CAN USE REAL
TIME EVEN RIGHT INSIDE OF A
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE ONLINE
EXCEPT HER SO THAT YOU CAN TEACH
THEM THE BASICS OF DISTORTED
MESSAGING ETCETERA- AND WOULD BE
REAL HARD TO PUT TOGETHER
IMAGINE I'M IN AGAIN YOU SURE
YOU'VE ALREADY DONE THAT THANK
YOU. THAT'S WHAT CLASSROOMS
SPECTRUM PLEASANT. HE'S OUR
SYSTEM IS. FROM MUSCLE PLANS BUT
- ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT. A LOT OF
ADULTS COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
FROM SOME OF THE TAX I GET. MOST
OF OUR SOCIAL MEDIA. THAT'S NOT
ALL OUR DOING UP HERE RIGHT-
BUT- BUT AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT AND RECOGNIZE HOW.
IMPORTANT IT IS TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE A DEMOCRACY. SO
WITH THAT MISTER BENNETT. I JUST
WANT TO. CONGRATULATE YOU FOR
COMING FOR WITH THIS YEAR I
THINK ABOUT THE IDEAL HIGH
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT THE IDEAL
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT I THINK HIGH
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THE TIME I
SPENT AND- IF YOU HAVE A GROUP
OF ADULTS IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO GET. THIS
GENERATION READY FOR THE EXTENT
THEY SHOULD BE CONSOLATION INTO
OF ALL OF THE TERMS OF WHAT IS
YOUNG PEOPLE NEED THIS SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE NEED. AND NOT WHAT
YOU PEOPLE DO ANYONE MUCH SUGAR
. AN CHOI TO INSTILL THAT. COOL
FOR. HE IS DIFFICULT AND THIS IS
AT LEAST AT LEAST OVERCOMES ONE
OF THE HURDLES- IN TERMS OF
MAKING THAT HAPPEN BUT IF WE CAN
BOTTLE AWAY TO HAVE PEOPLE
PROFESSIONALLY APPROACH THIS
THIS CHALLENGE AND IT OUGHT TO
BE SOME AT. IT GET THE MOST. G.
AND GETTING THE GENERATION READY
FOR THE NEXT STEP SO THANK YOU
FOR COMING FORWARD WITH THIS
BECAUSE THEY SAY AS WE PRIVACY
SAW YESTERDAY THIS IS JUST A
HUGE ISSUE AND THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE I GET THIS RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SUMMER. HERE AT THAT'S WHEN IT.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION. MOTION AND
SAT YOU MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF ADULTS THAT
COULD USE THIS THING AS WELL. TO
DO. A LITTLE BETTER THAN THAT.
THEN AND THEN WE'VE DONE- AND
ALSO JUST PROUD TO HAVE BOTH
TECH THE TECH INDUSTRY AN
ADVOCATE YOU DON'T ALWAYS SEE
EYE TO EY BOTH. PRO RESPECT
WERE. THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL HI DALLY BENNETT.
SENATE AYE CHAN LI'S MCCARTY
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA AYE
YEAH THREE THOUSAND RESULTS OKAY
SO THE BILL'S ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU WITH THAT
WERE TO GO TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WHICH IS ADAM
FOURTEEN. BY MR TANG. THANKYOU
MATURE LET ME JUST- THANK YOU IN
THE COMMITTEE ON ALL THE WORK ON
THIS BILL WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR GUIDANCE
ESPECIALLY. ON THE ISSUE MORE
RURAL DISTRICTS AND DISTRICTS
THAT- YOU KNOW FACE SOME HARDER
ACCESS TO RENEWABLE. REAL BRUTAL
ENERGY- AS WE ALL KNOW WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY VERY HARD TO.
BE OF A CLIMATE CHANGE REDUCE
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS FROM REDUCE
OUR GREENHOUSE GASES HEARING. WE
KNOW THAT FOR A CHILD IN SCHOOL
THAT WILL SCHOOL BY THE SCHOOL
BUS COMMUTE ACCOUNTS FOR ONLY
TEN PERCENT. OF HIS OR HER DAY
AS POLLUTANTS FROM AIR
POLLUTANTS FROM BUS BY ITS COVER
ABOUT THIRTY THREE PERCENT.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR
ANY BE TWENTY SEVEN. JUST AS THE
BALL NEWS BUT ZERO XIN BY THIRTY
FIVE. WE ALSO- EXTEND THAT TO
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES IN THESE
TWO CONTRACTS FOR ZERO EMISSION
BUSES AS WELL STARTING IN TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE REALLY. TO HAVE FROM
. FOR BUSES WHICH FALLS IN LINE
WITH OUR CLEAN CAR PROPOSAL THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS PUSHING FORWARD-
WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
MEMBERS THAT ALLOW A ONE TIME TO
YOUR EXTENSION FOR ALL. SCHOOLS
AND DISTRICTS WITH TERRAIN AND
ROW CONSTRAINTS PREVENTING THE
PURCHASE OR CONTRACTING OF A
ZERO EMISSION BUS. I THINK. VERY
GOOD PROPOSAL TO HELP US MOVE-
MOVE US TOWARD OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS WE HAVE A MR
LEVINE HERE FROM- TEAMSTERS AND-
CAMILLE OLSON FROM ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY. I'M SORRY
MISTLETOE SKEWED ME. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY- MY
NAME IS EMILY OLSON AND I AM A
POLICY PRINCIPLE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY
AND NATIONAL. OF ADVANCED ENERGY
INTO MOTION BUSINESSES IT OVERLY
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
SEVEN ONE THIS BILL SAYS A
REASONABLE ACHIEVABLE GOAL FOR
NEW SCHOOL BUS PURCHASES AND IT
ENABLE SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE
TO MAX TERMS GIVING SUCH. AS
SCHOOLS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
FROM THE BAY AREA TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO THE INLAND EMPIRE TO
SAN DIEGO ARE ALREADY
INCORPORATING ZERO MISSION
SCHOOL. TWEET THE TECHNOLOGY IS
MATURE IT'S PROVEN AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE RAPIDLY
ADVANCING TIME AND TIME AGAIN
ZERO EMISSION SCHOOL BUSES HAVE
PROVEN THEMSELVES TO BE A
RELIABLE RIDE. PERFORMING
SEAMLESSLY IN VARIOUS WEATHER
AND TERRAIN CONDITIONS THIS BILL
GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THIRTEEN
YEARS TO UNDERTAKE THE NECESSARY
PLANNING TO MEET THE TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE PURCHASE SINGLE SET.
IT WILL ALSO HELP HEALTH SCHOOLS
COMPETE FOR NEW FEDERAL FUNDING
FROM THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LOT SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION. CALIFORNIA'S NOT
MOUNTAIN LAMB WITH THIS TARGET
NOR IS ITS AMBITION BY ANY MEANS
UNMATCHED NEW YORK JUST SET A
MORE AGGRESSIVE REQUIREMENT THAT
ALL NEW SCHOOL BUS PURCHASES BE
ELECTRIC BY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
A FULL EIGHT YEARS EARLIER. THAN
WHAT OUR BILL PREPARE. SAFER
SCHOOLS IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THIS
WILL HELP INSURE THAT ALL
SCHOOLS CAN REAP THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL SAVINGS THAT
THEY CAN THEN RE AND BACK INTO
THE CLASSROOM WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY I FOR. THIRTY YOU
SOME. THANK YOU TO THE NEXT ONE
SEARCH J. LEVINE ON HALF OF
STUDENT FIRST NATIONAL EXPRESS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE ABOUT WAY BACK
FIRST STUDENT AT RESEARCH THE
COUNTRY MEETING FOR PROPERTY
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS SCHOOL
DIST OVER THE PROVIDING BUS
TRANSIT. L. CHAU EXTRA OPERATES
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE ALSO PRESENT
THIRTY FOUR STATES CURRENTLY AND
NOW OPERATES MORE THAN TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES AND
SAFETY AND SAFE WHICH REPORTS
ARE MILLION KIDS TODAY. TUNE IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE OPERATES IN
THIRTY THREE LOCATIONS SERVICING
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OPERATES THREE
THOUSAND BUSES IN THE STATE
EMPLOYS FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE
MOST OF WHOM BELONG. TO THE
TEACHERS UNION SAYS BREAST. BOTH
COMPANIES ARE LEADERS IN HIS OF
SPACE AND HAVE BEGUN TO DEPLOY
EVEN BUSES INTO THE RESPECTIVE
FLEETS FOR STUDENTS FOR WILL BE
DEPLOYING CLOSE TO NINETY BUSES
OVER THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
IN THE STATE. THE ELECTRIC ONE
OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS ENTRY IN
THE PLAINS OF BUSES IS THE
CURRENT CONTRACT AND IT'S TOO
SHORT. GIVEN THE EXPENSE OF
THESE BUSES AND IT TO BE A
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE SIX TO
REMEDY THAT BY LENGTHENING THE
CONTRACT BETWEEN OUR COMPANIES
IN THE DISTRICTS. WHICH
FACILITATES OUR ABILITY TO
PURCHASE WITH CONFIDENCE AND
COVER THE EXPENSE OF PURCHASING
NEW EVEY BUSES WE BELIEVE THIS
IS A VERY THOUGHTFUL POLICY THAT
WILL HELP EXPEDITE. OVERFLEW
DIESEL DESERVE A MENTION AND
MAKE IT ALL THAT MUCH SOONER WE
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE WORK I
MISSED CHIANG. THEIR COURAGE BY
IT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS INTO. TURN
MEMBER SALLY HOW THE NUMBER PER
SE NEXT IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
BACKGROUND ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND CAL
PERK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
. A SCENE OBSERVATION TO THE
BILL WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL MR TANG YOU KNOW I STRUGGLE
WITH THINGS LIKE THIS- RESET
YOUR- OKAY BUT BUT WHY- THE COST
FOR SURE. ABSOLUTELY THE
TECHNOLOGY IS IT THERE I'M NOT
AS CONVINCED AS SOME OTHERS ARE-
THAT IS TOTALLY THERE YET THAT
DOESN'T MEAN IT CAN'T BE BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND ALSO
JUST WE LOOK AT RURAL SIX HEADER
EVEN SOME URBAN JUST MORE THINGS
COME ONLINE. THAT ARE ELECTRIC-
DOES THE GRADE HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO TO SUPPORT THAT SO
THERE'S JUST SOME CONCERNS THAT.
I WANNA MAKE SURE. WHERE WHERE.
BUT IT MOVES. TO HAVE A SECOND.
MR LEE SECONDS- NO FURTHER
COMMITTEE COMMENT- YOU MAY CLOSE
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY THE I'VE I'VE
I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERNS AND
THAT THE CONCERN SHARED BY
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY
WE'VE PUT MONEY ASIDE WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE VOLKSWAGEN SETTLEMENT. FOR
SCHOOL BUSES I KNOW THAT WE SENT
ASIDE A SMALL R. NINETY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE SCHOOL
BUS REPLACEMENT PROGRAMS AGAIN
WE'RE VERY SENSITIVE OUT THERE
WE CAN BE MORE MONEY COMING
THROUGH THE G. OR F. PROGRAM WE
DEFINITELY. HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR WILL BE WILL BE DOING OUR
PART AS A STATE IN THAT WITHOUT
WILL RESPECT THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S- GREAT UP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WELL I DON'T KNOW
I DALLY. BENNETT SENATE I CHEN.
LI LEAI HE QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I OR BOTH THIS FOR
ALSO IS OUT AND I'D LIKE TO
COMPLIMENT MISTER LIVING ON A
STACK. SO WE WERE GENERATIONS.
OF THE WILL WE GO TO MOVE TO
CONSENT. YEAH WILL CONSENT TO
HAVE MISTER BENNETT MOVES MR THE
SECONDS CONSENT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON CONSENT. CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BAO AT NUMBER
FIFTEEN H. R. ONE OH ONE THE
MOTION IS THE ADOPTED WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB. THE MOTION. YES
FOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I DALY ALII BENNETT
SENATE I CHEN. PLEASE LEAI
MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA
EYES WE HAVE BY THE THAT'S FIVE
OH SO THAT IS OUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND WILL MOVE TO. WITH
TWO CALLS ONE OF THE CALLS FIRST. FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR. THAT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI DALLI DALLI AYE CHEN LI LI I
MCCARTY. AND FIVE AS FIVE OTOE
IT IS OUT. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE CHAN. LEE LEAI MCCARTY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I BY THE
THIS FIVE VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT. WE JUST HAVE ADD ONS NOW. I
THINK IS THAT WE GOT A GOOD
GROUP HERE YEAH YEAH- AND- YEAH
CALL THE CENTER. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE FOR THE ADAMS FILE
ITEM ONE AB. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE THE CHAIR VOTING I. SENATE
BENNETT I CHEN MCCARTY. FILE
ITEM THREE AB IN NINETEEN TWELVE
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D BENNETT.
SENATE I CHEN MCCARTY. FILE ITEM
FOR AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THE CHAIR VOTING I. CHEN MCCARTY. FILE ITEM FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE CHAN LI'S. LEAI. FILE ITEM
SIX AB TWO ZERO FIVE ONE THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE CHAN LI'S. B.
I. QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTEEN THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
CHAN LEE. FILE ITEM TEN A. B.
LEAI. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT. THE
CHAIR VOTING I CHAN LI LI I'VE.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE THE CHAIR
VOTING EYEING DALLY DALLY AYE
CHAN. THIRTY THANK GOODNESS- THE
MOBILE. MEETING IS ADJOURNED WE
WILL HOLD ROLE FOR ABOUT EIGHT
MINUTES FOR ANY MATTER ONCE AND
ON. THAT. I GUESS THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO ADD ON. GOT ABOUT EIGHT
MINUTES TO GET HERE AND- IF YOUR
ADD ONS. YEAH OKAY YEAH.
REPORTER. WE DON'T. AFTER. YES
HI. YEAH THAT WAS GREAT CLASS
WATER. OKAY EASIER. TO EVEN OPEN
HOUSE WE HAD. YEAH WILL
RECENTLY- A VIDEOS SOMETHING
YEAH. HELLO WITH THE RESERVATION
AND- YEAH THERE'S NO. AND STUFF
AND WE'RE GETTING WERE. WE AS
OUR FOR THE SENATE OF THE BILL
THE YEAR AND THE MORNING. HELLO
THIS IS A MESSAGE OKAY GOD.
WE'RE YEAH. OKAY RIGHT. BOB.
OKAY AND CONSENT CALENDAR THAT
YOU'RE VOTING I. CHEN MCCARTY
MCCARTY I'VE. C. FILE ITEM ONE
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE CHEN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I'VE- FILE ITEM
THREE AB NINETEEN TWELVE CHEN
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I'VE. FILE ITEM
FOR AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
CHEN MCCARTY. MCCARTY I'M. FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWO ZERO SIX FOUR
GEN MCCARTY MCCARTY I'VE. FILE
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR CHEN MCCARTY MCCARTY I'M.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE CHEN MCCARTY
MCCARTY I'VE- FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR GEN
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I'VE.
YEAH I HAD A FIFTY SIX BILLS
NEXT WEEK. YEAH THERE'S- YEAH.
YEAH THERE IS ACTUALLY AND- SO I
THINK THERE WAS POSTED THERE'S
ARTS ALREADY GOING TO BE HEARING
NEXT WEEK OF LIFE. OFFICE FORTY
THOUSAND. SIX YEAH THE DEAL IS
THE VIDEO WATCHING. I BET.
HERE'S ANOTHER. LOOKING FOR. YES
THIS IS TRUE THIS IS THE. OF ALL
. THIS BECAUSE IN THE HEADLINES
RIGHT. SIX OVER. YEAH WE THE
BILL HAS A ROOM. CONTACT BECAUSE
I ASKED AND I ZERO YEAH. YEAH
SOME FOR THE NETWORK. I LIKE HOW
PEOPLE LOOK AT THE.
YEAH YEAH. YOU WORK HARD. SHARKS. WE HAVE A FIFTEEN THANK YOU
WORKS FINANCIAL. YEAH WHAT'S UP-
YEAH. IT'S.
THERE IS.
MCCARTY AND- CONSENT CALENDAR
CHEN AYE CHAN AYE. FILE ITEM ONE
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE CHEN
ON JAN HI. FILE ITEM THREE AB
NINETEEN TWELVE CHEN HI CHEN I
FILE ITEM FOR AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT CHEN NUMBER IN.
CHEN NOT VOTING FILE ITEM FIVE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN CHEN
I CAN I'VE- FILE ITEM SIX AB TWO
ZERO FIVE ONE CHEN AYE CHAN AYE
. FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWO ZERO
SIX FOUR GEN I'M CHEN I. FILE
ITEM NINE AB TWO TWO ONE FOUR
CHEN NUMBER IN CHEN NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWO TWO ONE
FIVE CHEN HI GEN FIVE. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWO TWO EIGHT FOUR
CHEN CHEN I AM. A FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWO SIX THREE EIGHT
CHEN HI CHEN I. FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWO SEVEN THREE ONE
CHEN HI CHEN I. AND FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN A. B. TWO THREE SIX FOUR
CHEN CHEN I'D.
PLEASE OKAY
-
IT WAS IT WAS- REALLY.